gildan media presents
ikigai the japanese secret to a long and
happy life
written by hector garcia and francesc
miraes
translated by heather cleary read by
walter dixon
prologue ikigai
a mysterious word
this audiobook first came into being on
a rainy night in tokyo when its authors
sat down together for the first time in
one of the city's tiny bars
we had each read each other's work but
had never met thanks to the thousands of
miles that separate barcelona from the
capital of japan
then a mutual acquaintance put us in
touch launching a friendship that led to
this project
and seems destined to last a lifetime
the next time we got together a year
later
we strolled through a park in downtown
tokyo and ended up talking about trends
in western psychology
specifically logotherapy which helps
people find their purpose in life
we remarked that victor frankel's logo
therapy had gone out of fashion among
practicing therapists
who favored other schools of psychology
though people still search for meaning
in what they do
and how they live we ask ourselves
things like
what is the meaning of my life is the
point just to live longer or
should i seek a higher purpose why do
some people know what they want and have
a passion for life
while others languish in confusion
at some point in our conversation the
mysterious word ikigai
came up this japanese concept which
translates roughly as the happiness of
always being busy
is like logotherapy but it goes a step
beyond
it also seems to be one way of
explaining the extraordinary longevity
of the japanese
especially on the island of okinawa
where there are 24.55 people
over the age of 100 for every 100 000
inhabitants
far more than the global average those
who study why the inhabitants of this
island in the south of japan
live longer than people anywhere else in
the world believe that one of the keys
in addition to a healthful diet a simple
life in the outdoors
green tea and the sub-tropical climate
its average temperatures like that of
hawaii
is the icky guy that shapes their lives
while researching this concept we
discovered that not a single book in the
fields of psychology or personal
development
is dedicated to bringing this philosophy
to the west
is ikigai the reason there are more
centenarians in okinawa than anywhere
else
how does it inspire people to stay
active until the very end
what is the secret to a long and happy
life
as we explored the matter further we
discovered that one place in particular
ogimi a rural town on the north end of
the island with a population of three
thousand
boasts the highest life expectancy in
the world
a fact that has earned it the nickname
of the village of longevity
okinawa is where most of japan's
shikawasa
a limelike fruit that packs an
extraordinary antioxidant punch comes
from
could that be ogimi's secret to long
life or is it the purity of the water
used to brew its moringa tea
we decided to go study the secrets of
the japanese centenarians in person
after a year of preliminary research we
arrived in the village
where residents speak an ancient dialect
and practice an animist religion that
features long-haired forest sprites
called bunagaya
with our cameras and recording devices
in hand
as soon as we arrived we could sense the
incredible friendliness of its residents
who laughed and joked incessantly amid
lush green hills fed by crystalline
waters
as we conducted our interviews with the
eldest residents of the town
we realized that something far more
powerful than just these natural
resources was at work
an uncommon joy flows from its
inhabitants and guides them through the
long and pleasurable journey of their
lives
again the mysterious icky guy
but what is it exactly how do you get it
it never cease to surprise us that this
haven of nearly eternal life
was located precisely in okinawa where
200
000 innocent lives were lost at the end
of world war ii
rather than harbor animosity toward
outsiders however okinawans live by the
principle of
ichariba chode a local expression that
means
treat everyone like a brother even if
you've never met them before
it turns out that one of the secrets to
happiness of ogimi's residents is
feeling like
part of a community from an early age
they practice yuiru
or teamwork and so are used to helping
one another
nurturing friendships eating light
getting enough rest
and doing regular moderate exercise are
all part of the equation of good health
but at the heart of the joie de vivre
that inspires these centenarians to keep
celebrating birthdays and cherishing
each new day
is their ikigai the purpose of this
audiobook is to bring the secrets of
japan's centenarians to you
and give you the tools to find your own
ikigai because those who discover their
ikigai have
everything they need for a long and
joyful journey through life
happy travels hector garcia and francesc
mirais
chapter 1 ikigai
the art of staying young while growing
old
what is your reason for being according
to the japanese
everyone has an ikigai what a french
philosopher might call a
raison d'etre some people have found
their ikigai
while others are still looking though
they carry it within them
our ikigai is hidden deep inside each of
us and finding it
requires a patient search according to
those born on okinawa
the island with the most centenarians in
the world our ikigai
is the reason we get up in the morning
ikigai can be described as the common
ground you find between
what you're good at what you love what
the world needs
and what you can be paid for
whatever you do don't retire
having a clearly defined ikigai brings
satisfaction
happiness and meaning to our lives the
purpose of this audiobook is to help you
find yours
and to share insights from japanese
philosophy on the lasting health of body
mind and spirit one surprising thing you
notice living in japan is
how active people remain after they
retire in fact many japanese people
never really retire
they keep doing what they love for as
long as their health allows
there is in fact no word in japanese
that means retire in the sense of
leaving the workforce for good as in
english
according to dan buettner a national
geographic reporter who knows the
country well
having a purpose in life is so important
in japanese culture that
our idea of retirement simply doesn't
exist there
the island of almost eternal youth
certain longevity studies suggest that a
strong sense of community
and a clearly defined ikigai are just as
important as the famously healthful
japanese diet
perhaps even more so recent medical
studies of centenarians from okinawa and
other so-called
blue zones the geographic regions were
people of longest
provide a number of interesting facts
about these extraordinary human beings
not only do they live much longer than
the rest of the world's population
they also suffer from fewer chronic
illnesses such as cancer and heart
disease
inflammatory disorders are also less
common
many of these centenarians enjoy
enviable levels of vitality and health
that would be unthinkable for people of
advanced age elsewhere
their blood tests reveal fewer free
radicals which are responsible for
cellular aging
as a result of drinking tea and eating
until their stomachs are only 80 percent
full
women experience more moderate symptoms
during menopause
and both men and women maintain higher
levels of sexual hormones until much
later in life
the rate of dementia is well below the
global average
though we'll consider each of these
findings over the course of the
audiobook
research clearly indicates that the
okinawan's focus on ikigai
gives a sense of purpose to each and
every day and plays an important role in
their health and longevity
the characters behind ikigai
in japanese ikigai is written by
combining
a character which means life with
another which means
to be worthwhile and that can be broken
down to the characters which mean
armor number one and to be the first
to head into battle taking initiative as
a leader and
another character which means beautiful
or elegant
the five blue zones
okinawa holds first place among the
world's blue zones
in okinawa women in particular live
longer and have fewer diseases than
anywhere else in the world
the five regions identified and analyzed
by dan buettner in his book
the blue zones are 1.
okinawa japan especially the northern
part of the island
the locals either died rich in
vegetables and tofu
typically served on small plates in
addition to their philosophy
of ikigai the moai or close-knit group
of friends
plays an important role in their
longevity
2. sardinia italy specifically the
provinces of nuoro and oklahostra
locals on this island consume plenty of
vegetables and one or two glasses of
wine per day
as in okinawa the cohesive nature of
this community is another factor
directly related to longevity
3. loma linda california
researchers studied a group of
seventh-day adventists who are among the
longest living people in the united
states
four the nicoya peninsula costa rica
locals remain remarkably active after
90. many of the region's older residents
have no problem getting up at 5 30 in
the morning to work in the fields
5. icaria greece
one of every three inhabitants of this
island near the coast of turkey is over
90 years old
compared to less than one percent of the
population of the united states
a fact that is earned at the nickname of
the island of long life
the local secret seems to be a lifestyle
that dates back to 500 bc
in the following chapters we'll examine
several factors that seem to be the keys
to longevity
and are found across the blue zones
paying special attention to okinawa and
its so-called
village of longevity first however it's
worth pointing out that three of these
regions are islands
where resources can be scarce and
communities have to help one another
for many helping others might be an
ikigai strong enough to keep them alive
according to scientists who have studied
the five blue zones the keys to
longevity are
diet exercise finding a purpose in life
an ikigai and forming strong social ties
that is having a broad circle of friends
and good family relations
members of these communities manage
their time well in order to reduce
stress
consume little meat or processed foods
and drink alcohol in moderation
they don't do strenuous exercise but
they do move every day
taking walks and working in their
vegetable gardens people in the blue
zones would rather walk than drive
gardening which involves daily low
intensity movement is a practice almost
all of them have in common
the 80 percent secret
one of the most common sayings in japan
is
which is repeated before or after eating
and means something like
fill your belly to 80 percent ancient
wisdom advises against eating until we
are full
this is why okinawans stop eating when
they feel their stomachs reach
80 percent of their capacity rather than
overeating and wearing down their bodies
with long digestive processes
that accelerate cellular oxidation
of course there's no way to know
objectively if your stomach is at eighty
percent capacity
the lesson to learn from this saying is
that we should stop eating when we're
starting to feel full
the extra side dish the snack we eat
when we know in our hearts we don't
really need it
the apple pie after lunch all these will
give us pleasure in the short term
but not having them will make us happier
in the long term
the way food is served is also important
by presenting their meals on many small
plates
the japanese tend to eat less a typical
meal in a restaurant in japan is served
in
five plates on a tray four of them very
small
and the main dish slightly bigger having
five plates in front of you makes it
seem like you're going to eat a lot
but what happens most of the time is
that you end up feeling slightly hungry
this is one of the reasons why
westerners in japan typically lose
weight
and stay trim recent studies by
nutritionists reveal that okinawans
consume
a daily average of 1800 to 1900 calories
compared to 2200 to 3 300 in the united
states
and have a body mass index between 18
and 22
compared to 26 or 27 in the united
states
the okinawan diet is rich in tofu sweet
potatoes
fish three times per week and vegetables
roughly 11 ounces per day
in the chapter dedicated to nutrition
we'll see which healthy antioxidant rich
foods are included in this 80 percent
moai connected for life
it is customary in okinawa to form close
bonds within local communities
a moai is an informal group of people
with common interests who look out for
one another
for many serving the community becomes
part of their ikigai
the moai has its origins in hard times
when farmers would get together to share
best practices and help one another cope
with meager harvests
members of a moai make a set monthly
contribution to the group
this payment allows them to participate
in meetings dinners
games of go and shogi japanese chess or
whatever hobby they have in common the
funds collected by the group are used
for activities
but if there's money left over one
member decided on a rotating basis
receives a set amount from the surplus
in this way
being part of a moai helps maintain
emotional and financial stability
if a member of a moai is in financial
trouble he or she can get an advance
from the group's savings
while the details of each moai's
accounting practices vary according to
the group and its economic means
the feeling of belonging and support
gives the individual
a sense of security and helps increase
life expectancy
following this brief introduction to the
topics covered in this audio book
we look at a few causes of premature
aging in modern life
and then explore different factors
related to ikigai
chapter 2 anti-aging secrets
little things that add up to a long and
happy life
aging's escape velocity and the rabbit
imagine a sign far off in the future
with a number on it that represents the
age of your death
every year that you live you advance
closer to the sign
when you reach the sign you die now
imagine a rabbit holding the sign and
walking to the future
every year that you live the rabbit is
half a year as far away
after a while you will reach the rabbit
and die
but what if the rabbit could walk at a
pace of one year
for every year of your life you would
never be able to catch the rabbit
and therefore you would never die the
speed at which the rabbit walks to the
future
is our technology the more we advance
technology and knowledge of our bodies
the faster we can make the rabbit walk
aging's escape velocity
is the moment at which the rabbit walks
at a pace of one year
per year or faster and we become
immortal
aging's escape velocity
for more than a century we've managed to
add an average of 0.3 years to our life
expectancy every year
but what would happen if we had the
technology to add a year of life
expectancy
every year in theory we would achieve
biological immortality
having reached aging's escape velocity
researchers with a night of the future
such as ray kurzweil and aubry de gray
claim that we'll reach this escape
velocity in a matter of decades
other scientists are less optimistic
predicting that we'll reach a limit
a maximum age we won't be able to
surpass no matter how much technology we
have
for example some biologists assert that
our cells stop regenerating
after about 120 years
active mind youthful body
there is much wisdom in the classic
saying men's sana in corpore sano
a sound mind and a sound body it reminds
us that both mind and body are important
and that the health of one is connected
to that of the other
it's been shown that maintaining an
active adaptable mind
is one of the key factors in staying
young
having a youthful mind also drives you
toward a healthy lifestyle that will
slow the aging process
just as a lack of physical exercise has
negative effects on our bodies and mood
a lack of mental exercise is bad for us
because it causes our neurons and neural
connections to deteriorate
and as a result reduces our ability to
react to our surroundings
this is why it's so important to give
your brain a workout
one pioneer in advocating for mental
exercise is the israeli neuroscientist
[ __ ] breznitz
who argues that the brain needs a lot of
stimulation in order to stay in shape
as he stated in an interview with edward
punset for the spanish
television program redis
there is a tension between what is good
for someone and what they want to do
this is because people especially older
people like to do things as they've
always done them
the problem is that when the brain
develops ingrained habits it doesn't
need to think anymore
things get done quickly and efficiently
on automatic pilot
often in a very advantageous way this
creates a tendency to stick to routines
and the only way of breaking these is to
confront the brain with
new information
presented with new information the brain
creates new connections
and is revitalized this is why it's so
important to expose yourself to change
even if stepping outside your comfort
zone means feeling a bit of anxiety
the effects of mental training have been
scientifically demonstrated
according to collins hemingway and
[ __ ] breznitz in their book
maximum brain power challenging the
brain for health and wisdom
mental training is beneficial on many
levels
you begin exercising your brain by doing
a certain task for the first time
he writes and at first it seems very
difficult
but as you learn how to do it the
training is already working
the second time you realize that it's
easier not harder to do because you're
getting better at it
this has a fantastic effect on a
person's mood in and of itself
it's a transformation that affects not
only the results obtained
but also his or her self-image
this description of a mental workout
might sound a bit formal
but simply interacting with others
playing a game for example
offers new stimuli and helps prevent the
depression that can come with solitude
our neurons start to age while we're
still in our 20s
this process is slowed however by
intellectual activity
curiosity and a desire to learn
dealing with new situations learning
something new every day
playing games and interacting with other
people seem to be essential for
anti-aging strategies for the mind
furthermore a more positive outlook in
this regard will yield
greater mental benefits
stress accused of killing longevity
many people seem older than they are
research into the causes of premature
aging has shown that stress has a lot to
do with it
because the body wears down much faster
during periods of crisis
the american institute of stress
investigated this degenerative process
and concluded that
most health problems are caused by
stress
researchers at the heidelberg university
hospital conducted a study in which
they subjected a young doctor to a job
interview which
they made even more stressful by forcing
him to solve complex math problems for
30 minutes
afterward they took a blood sample what
they discovered was that
his antibodies had reacted to stress the
same way they react to pathogens
activating the proteins that trigger an
immune response
the problem is that this response not
only neutralizes harmful agents
it also damages healthy cells leading
them to age prematurely
the university of california conducted a
similar study taking data and samples
from 39 women who had high levels of
stress due to the illness of one of
their children
and comparing them to samples from women
with healthy children and low levels of
stress
they found that stress promotes cellular
aging by weakening cell structures known
as
telomeres which affect cellular
regeneration and how our cells age
as the study revealed the greater the
stress the greater the degenerative
effects on cells
how does stress work these days
people live at a frantic pace and in a
nearly constant state of competition
at this fever pitch stress is a natural
response to the information being
received by the body is
potentially dangerous or problematic
theoretically this is a useful reaction
as it helps us survive in hostile
surroundings
over the course of our evolution we have
used this response to deal with
difficult situations
and to flee from predators the alarm
that goes off in our head
makes our neurons activate the pituitary
gland which produces hormones that
release corticotropin
which in turn circulates through the
body via the sympathetic nervous system
the adrenal gland is then triggered to
release adrenaline and cortisol
adrenaline raises our respiratory rate
and pulse and prepares our muscles for
action
getting the body ready to react to
perceived danger while cortisol
increases the release of dopamine and
blood glucose which is what gets us
charged up and allows us to face
challenges
these processes are in moderation
beneficial
they help us overcome challenges in our
daily lives
nonetheless the stress to which human
beings are subjected today
is clearly harmful compare the lives of
cave dwellers with modern humans cave
dwellers
were relaxed most of the time modern
humans
work most of the time and are alert to
any and all threats
cave dwellers felt stress only in very
specific situations
modern humans are online or waiting for
notifications from their cell phones 24
hours a day
to cave dwellers the threats were real a
predator could end their lives at any
moment
for modern humans the brain associates
the ping of a cell phone or an email
notification with the threat of a
predator
for cave dwellers high doses of cortisol
and adrenaline at moments of danger kept
the body healthy
in modern humans low doses of cortisol
flow constantly through the body
with implications for a range of health
problems including adrenal fatigue
and chronic fatigue syndrome stress has
a degenerative effect over time a
sustained state of emergency affects the
neurons associated with memory
as well as inhibiting the release of
certain hormones the absence of which
can cause depression
its secondary effects include
irritability insomnia
anxiety and high blood pressure as such
though challenges are good for keeping
mind and body active
we should adjust our high stress
lifestyles in order to avoid the
premature aging of our bodies
be mindful about reducing stress
whether or not the threats we perceive
are real stresses an easily identifiable
condition that not only causes anxiety
but is also highly psychosomatic
affecting everything from
our digestive system to our skin
this is why prevention is so important
in avoiding the toll that stress takes
on us
and why many experts recommend
practicing mindfulness
the central premise of this stress
reduction method is focusing on the self
noticing our responses even if they are
conditioned by habit
in order to be fully conscious of them
in this way
we connect with the here and now and
limit thoughts that tend to spiral out
of control
we have to learn to turn off the
autopilot that's steering us in an
endless loop
we all know people who snack while
talking on the phone or watching the
news
you ask them if the omelette they just
ate had an onion in it and they can't
tell you
says roberto alcibar who abandoned his
fast-paced life to become a certified
instructor of mindfulness
after an illness threw him into a period
of acute stress
one way to reach such a state of
mindfulness is through meditation
which helps filter the information that
reaches us from the outside world
it can also be achieved through
breathing exercises yoga
and body scans achieving mindfulness
involves a gradual process of training
but with a bit of practice we can learn
to focus our mind completely
which reduces stress and helps us live
longer
a little stress is good for you
while sustained intense stress is a
known enemy of longevity
and both mental and physical health low
levels of stress have been shown to be
beneficial
after observing a group of test subjects
for more than 20 years
dr howard s friedman a psychology
professor at the university of
california riverside
discovered that people who maintained a
low level of stress
who face challenges and put their heart
and soul into their work in order to
succeed
lived longer than those who chose a more
relaxed lifestyle
and retired earlier from this
he concluded that a small dose of stress
is a positive thing
as those who live with low levels of
stress tend to develop healthier habits
smoke less and drink less alcohol
given this it's not surprising that many
of the super centenarians
people who live to be 110 or more whom
you'll meet in this audiobook
talk about having lived intense lives
and working well into old age
a lot of sitting will age you
in the western world in particular the
rise in sedentary behavior has led to
numerous diseases such as hypertension
and obesity
which in turn affect longevity spending
too much time seated at work or at home
not only reduces muscular and
respiratory fitness but also increases
appetite
and curbs the desire to participate in
activities
being sedentary can lead to hypertension
imbalanced eating
cardiovascular disease osteoporosis and
even certain kinds of cancer
recent studies have shown a connection
between a lack of physical activity
and the progressive distortion of
telomeres in the immune system
which ages those cells and in turn the
organism as a whole
this is a problem at all life stages not
only among adults
sedentary children suffer from high
rates of obesity and all its associated
health issues and risks
which is why it's so important to
develop a healthy and active lifestyle
in an early age
it's easy to be less sedentary it just
takes a bit of effort and a few changes
to your routine
we can access a more active lifestyle
that makes us feel better inside and out
we just have to add a few ingredients to
our everyday habits
walk to work or just go on a walk for at
least 20 minutes each day
use your feet instead of an elevator or
escalator
this is good for your posture your
muscles and your respiratory system
among other things
participate in social or leisure
activities so that you don't spend too
much time in front of the television
replace your junk food with fruit and
you'll have less of an urge to snack
and more nutrients in your system
get the right amount of sleep seven to
nine hours is good
but any more than that makes us
lethargic
play with children or pets or join a
sports team
this not only strengthens the body but
also stimulates the mind
and boosts self-esteem
be conscious of your daily routine in
order to detect harmful habits
and replace them with more positive ones
by making these small changes we can
begin to renew our bodies and minds
and increase our life expectancy
a model's best kept secret
though we age both externally and
internally both physically and mentally
one of the things that tell us the most
about people's age is their skin
which takes on different textures and
colors according to processes going on
beneath the surface
most of those who make their living as
models claim to sleep between nine and
ten hours the night before a fashion
show
this gives their skin a taut
wrinkle-free appearance and a healthy
radiant glow
science has shown that sleep is a key
anti-aging tool
because when we sleep we generate
melatonin a hormone that occurs
naturally in our bodies
the pineal gland produces it from the
neurotransmitter serotonin
according to our diurnal and nocturnal
rhythms and it plays a role in our sleep
and waking cycles
a powerful antioxidant melatonin helps
us live longer
and also offers the following benefits
it strengthens the immune system
it contains an element that protects
against cancer
it promotes the natural production of
insulin it slows the onset of
alzheimer's disease
it helps prevent osteoporosis and fight
heart disease
for all these reasons melatonin is a
great ally in preserving youth
it should be noted however that
melatonin production decreases after age
30.
we can compensate for this by eating a
balanced diet
and getting more calcium soaking up a
moderate amount of sun each day
getting enough sleep avoiding stress
alcohol tobacco and caffeine all of
which make it harder to get a good
night's rest
depriving us of the melatonin we need
experts are trying to determine whether
artificially stimulating production of
melatonin
might help slow the aging process which
would confirm the theory that we already
carry the secret to longevity within us
anti-aging attitudes
the mind has tremendous power over the
body and how quickly it ages
most doctors agree that the secret to
keeping the body young is keeping the
mind active
a key element of ikigai and not caving
in when we face difficulties throughout
our lives
one study conducted at yeshiva
university found that
the people who live the longest have two
dispositional traits in common
a positive attitude and a high degree of
emotional awareness
in other words those who face challenges
with a positive outlook
and are able to manage their emotions
are already well on their way toward
longevity
a stoic attitude serenity in the face of
a setback
can also help keep you young as it
lowers anxiety and stress levels
and stabilizes behavior this can be seen
in the greater life expectancies of
certain cultures with
unhurried deliberate lifestyles
many centenarians and super centenarians
have similar profiles
they've had full lives that were
difficult at times but
they knew how to approach these
challenges with a positive attitude
and not be overwhelmed by the obstacles
they faced
alexander image who in 2014 became the
world's oldest living man at age 111
knew he had good genes but understood
that other factors contributed too
the life you live is equally or more
important for longevity
he said in an interview with reuters
after being added to guinness world
records
in 2014
an ode to longevity
during our stay in ogimi the village
that holds the guinness record for
longevity
a woman who was about to turn 100 years
old sang the following song for us in a
mixture of japanese and the local
dialect
to keep healthy and have a long life eat
just a little of everything with relish
go to bed early get up early and then go
out for a walk
we live each day with serenity and we
enjoy the journey
to keep healthy and have a long life we
get unwell with all our friends
spring summer fall winter we happily
enjoy all the seasons
the secret is not to get distracted by
how old the fingers are
from the fingers to the head and back
once again
if you keep moving with your fingers
working
100 years will come to you
we can now use our fingers to play the
next chapter where we'll look at the
close relationship between longevity
and discovering our life's mission
chapter 3 from logotherapy
to ikigai how to live longer and better
by finding your purpose
what is logotherapy
a colleague once asked victor frankl to
define his school of psychology in a
single phrase
to which frankl replied well in
logotherapy the patient sits up straight
and has to listen to things that are on
occasion hard to hear
the colleague had just described
psychoanalysis to him in the following
terms
in psychoanalysis the patient lies down
on a couch and tells you things that are
on occasion hard to say
frankel explains that one of the first
questions he would ask his patients was
why do you not commit suicide usually
the patient found good reasons not to
and was able to carry on what then does
logotherapy do
the answer is pretty clear it helps you
find
reasons to live logotherapy pushes
patients to consciously discover their
life's purpose
in order to confront their neuroses
their quest to fulfill their destiny
then motivates them to press forward
breaking the mental chains of the past
and overcoming whatever obstacles they
encounter along the way
something to live for
a study conducted by frankel in his
vienna clinic found that among both
patients and personnel
around 80 percent believed that human
beings needed a reason for living
and around 60 percent felt they had
someone or something in their lives
worth dying for
the search for meaning
the search for purpose became a personal
driving force that allowed frankl to
achieve his goals
the process of logo therapy can be
summarized in these five steps
one a person feels empty frustrated or
anxious
two the therapist shows him that what he
is feeling is the desire to have a
meaningful life
three the patient discovers his life's
purpose
at that particular point in time four
of his own free will the patient decides
to accept or reject that destiny
5. this newfound passion for life helps
him overcome
obstacles and sorrows frankel himself
would live and die for his principles
and ideals
his experiences as a prisoner at
auschwitz showed him that
everything can be taken from a man but
one thing
the last of the human freedoms to choose
one's attitude in any given set of
circumstances
to choose one's own way
it was something he had to go through
alone without any help
and it inspired him for the rest of his
life
10 differences between psychoanalysis
and logotherapy
psychoanalysis the patient reclines on a
couch like a patient
logotherapy the patient sits facing the
therapist
who guides him or her without passing
judgment
psychoanalysis is retrospective it looks
to the past
logotherapy looks toward the future
psychoanalysis is introspective it
analyzes neuroses
logotherapy does not delve into the
patient's neuroses
in psychoanalysis the drive is toward
pleasure
in logotherapy the drive is toward
purpose and meaning
psychoanalysis centers on psychology
logotherapy
includes a spiritual dimension
psychoanalysis works on
psychogenic neuroses logotherapy also
works on noeogenic or
existential neuroses psychoanalysis
analyzes the unconscious origin of
conflicts instinctual dimension
logotherapy deals with conflicts when
and where they arise
spiritual dimension psychoanalysis
limits itself to the patient's instincts
logotherapy
also deals with spiritual realities
psychoanalysis is fundamentally
incompatible with faith
logotherapy is compatible with faith
psychoanalysis seeks to reconcile
conflicts and satisfy impulses and
instincts
logotherapy seeks to help the patient
find meaning in his life
and satisfy his moral principles
fight for yourself
existential frustration arises when our
life is without purpose
or when that purpose is skewed in
frankel's view however
there's no need to see this frustration
as an anomaly or a symptom of neurosis
instead it can be a positive thing a
catalyst for change
logotherapy does not see this
frustration as mental illness
the way other forms of therapy do but
rather as spiritual anguish
a natural and beneficial phenomenon that
drives those who suffer from it
to seek a cure whether on their own or
with the help of others
and in so doing find greater
satisfaction in life
it helps them change their own destiny
logotherapy enters the picture if a
person needs help doing this
if he needs guidance in discovering his
life's purpose and
later in overcoming conflict so we can
keep moving towards his objective
in man's search for meaning frankl cites
one of nietzsche's famous aphorisms
he who has a why to live can bear with
almost
any how based on his own experience
frankel believed that our health depends
on that natural tension that comes from
comparing what we've accomplished so far
with what we'd like to achieve in the
future
what we need then is not a peaceful
existence
but a challenge we can strive to meet by
applying all the skills at our disposal
existential crisis on the other hand is
typical of modern societies in which
people do what they're told to do or
what others do rather than
what they want to do they often try to
fill the gap between what is expected of
them and what they want for themselves
with
economic power or physical pleasure or
by numbing their senses
it can even lead to suicide
sunday neurosis for example is what
happens when
without the obligations and commitments
of the work week the individual realizes
how empty he is inside
he has to find a solution above all he
has to find his purpose
his reason for getting out of bed is
ikigai
i feel empty inside
in a study conducted at the vienna poly
clinic hospital frankel's team found
that 55 percent of the patients they
interviewed
were experiencing some degree of
existential crisis
according to logotherapy discovering
one's purpose in life helps an
individual fill that existential void
frankl a man who faced his problems and
turned his objectives into actions
could look back on his life in peace as
he grew old
he did not have to envy those still
enjoying their youth because he had
amassed a broad set of experiences that
showed
he had lived for something
better living through logotherapy a few
key ideas
we don't create the meaning of our life
as sartre claimed
we discover it
we each have a unique reason for being
which can be adjusted or transformed
many times over the years
just as worry often brings about
precisely the thing that was feared
excessive attention to a desire or hyper
intention
can keep that desire from being
fulfilled
humor can help break negative cycles and
reduce anxiety
we all have the capacity to do noble or
terrible things
the side of the equation we end up on
depends on our decisions
not on the condition in which we find
ourselves
in the following case studies we'll look
at four cases from frankel's own
practice
in order to better understand the search
for meaning and purpose
case study victor frankel
in german concentration camps as in
those that would later be built in japan
and korea
psychiatrists confirmed that the
prisoners with the greatest chance of
survival
were those who had things they wanted to
accomplish outside the camp
those who felt a strong need to get out
of there alive
this was true of frankel who after being
released and successfully developing the
school of logotherapy
realized he had been the first patient
of his own practice
frankel had a goal to achieve and it
made him persevere
he arrived at auschwitz carrying a
manuscript that contained all the
theories and research he compiled over
the course of his career
ready for publication when it was
confiscated
he felt compelled to write it all over
again and that need drove him
and gave his life meaning amid the
constant horror and doubt of the
concentration camp
so much so that over the years and
especially when he fell ill with typhus
he would jot down fragments and key
words from the lost work
on any scrap of paper he found
case study the american diplomat
an important north american diplomat
went to frankel to pick up where he left
off with a course of treatment he had
started five years earlier in the united
states
when frankl asked him why he'd started
therapy in the first place
the diplomat answered that he hated his
job and his country's international
policies
which he had to follow and enforce his
american psychoanalyst whom he'd been
seeing for years
insisted he make peace with his father
so that his government
and his job both representations of the
paternal figure
would seem less disagreeable frankel
however
showed him in just a few sessions that
his frustration was due to the fact that
he wanted to pursue a different career
and the diplomat concluded his treatment
with that idea in mind
five years later the former diplomat
informed frankel that
he'd been working during that time in a
different profession and that he was
happy
in frankel's view the man not only
didn't need all those years of
psychoanalysis
he also couldn't even really be
considered a patient in native therapy
he was simply someone in search of a new
life's purpose
as soon as he found it his life took on
deeper meaning
case study the suicidal mother
the mother of a boy who had died at age
11 was admitted to frankel's clinic
after she tried to kill herself and her
other son
it was this other son paralyzed since
birth who kept her from carrying out her
plan
he did believe his life had a purpose
and if his mother killed them both
it would keep him from achieving his
goals
the woman shared her story in a group
session
to help her frankel asked another woman
to imagine a hypothetical situation in
which
she lay on her deathbed old and wealthy
but childless
the woman insisted that in that case she
would have felt her life had been a
failure
when the suicidal mother was asked to
perform the same exercise
imagining herself on her deathbed she
looked back and realized that
she had done everything in her power for
her children for both of them
she had given her paralyzed son a good
life and he had turned into a kind
reasonably happy person to this she
added crying
as for myself i can look back peacefully
on my life for i can say my life was
full of meaning
and i have tried hard to live it fully i
have done my best
i've done my best for my son my life was
no failure
in this way by imagining herself on her
deathbed and looking back
the suicidal mother found the meaning
that though she was not aware of it
her life already had
case study the grief-stricken doctor
an elderly doctor unable to overcome the
deep depression into which he'd fallen
after the death of his wife two years
earlier
went to frankel for help instead of
giving him advice or
analyzing his condition frankel asked
him what would have happened
if he had been the one who died first
the doctor horrified answered that
it would have been terrible for his poor
wife that she would have suffered
tremendously
to which frankl responded you see doctor
you've spared her all that suffering but
the price you have to pay for this
is to survive and mourn her
the doctor didn't say another word he
left frankel's office in peace
after taking the therapists hand in his
own
he was able to tolerate the pain in
place of his beloved wife
his life had been given a purpose
morita therapy
in the same decade that logotherapy came
into being a few years earlier in fact
shoma morita created his own
purpose-centered therapy in japan
it proved to be effective in the
treatment of neurosis
obsessive-compulsive disorder
and post-traumatic stress in addition to
being a psychotherapist
shoma morita was a zen buddhist and his
therapy left a lasting spiritual mark on
japan
many western forms of therapy focus on
controlling or modifying the patient's
emotions
in the west we tend to believe that what
we think influences how we feel
which in turn influences how we act in
contrast
morita therapy focuses on teaching
patients to accept their emotions
without trying to control them
since their feelings will change as a
result of their actions
in addition to accepting the patient's
emotions morita therapy
seeks to create new emotions on the
basis of actions
according to marita these emotions are
learned through experience and
repetition
morita therapy is not meant to eliminate
symptoms
instead it teaches us to accept our
desires anxieties fears and worries
and let them go as morita writes in his
book
morita therapy and the true nature of
anxiety-based disorders
in feelings it is best to be wealthy and
generous
marita explained the idea of letting go
of negative feelings with the following
fable
a donkey that is tied to a post by a
rope will keep walking around the post
in an attempt to free
itself only to become more immobilized
and attached to the post
the same thing applies to people with
obsessive thinking who become more
trapped in their own suffering
when they try to escape from their fears
and discomfort
the basic principles of morita therapy
one accept your feelings
if we have obsessive thoughts we should
not try to control them or get rid of
them
if we do they become more intense
regarding human emotions
the zen master would say if we try to
get rid of one wave with another
we end up with an infinite sea
we don't create our feelings they simply
come to us and we have to accept them
the trick is welcoming them morita
likened emotions to the weather
we can't predict or control them we can
only observe them
to this point he often quoted the
vietnamese monk tic not han
who would say hello solitude how are you
today
come sit with me and i will care for you
two do what you should be doing
we shouldn't focus on eliminating
symptoms because recovery will come on
its own
we should focus instead on the present
moment and if we're suffering
on accepting that suffering above all we
should avoid intellectualizing the
situation
the therapist's mission is to develop
the patient's character so he or she can
face any situation and character
is grounded in the things we do morita
therapy does not offer its patients
explanations
but rather allows them to learn from
their actions and activities
it doesn't tell you how to meditate or
how to keep a diary the way western
therapies do
it's up to the patient to make
discoveries through experience
three discover your life's purpose
we can't control our emotions but we can
take charge of our actions every day
this is why we should have a clear sense
of our purpose and always keep morita's
mantra in mind
what do we need to be doing right now
what action should we be taking the key
to achieving this
is having dared to look inside yourself
to find
your ikigai
the four phases of morita therapy
morita's original treatment which lasts
15 to 21 days
consists of the following stages one
isolation and rest five to seven days
during the first week of treatment the
patient rests in a room without any
external stimuli
no television books family friends or
speaking all the patient has is his
thoughts
he lies down for most of the day and is
visited regularly by the therapist
who tries to avoid interacting with him
as much as possible
the therapist simply advises the patient
to continue observing the rise and fall
of his emotions as he lies there
when the patient gets bored and wants to
start doing things again
he's ready to move on to the next stage
of therapy
two light occupational therapy
five to seven days in this stage
the patient performs repetitive tasks in
silence
one of these is keeping a diary about
his thoughts and feelings
the patient goes outside after a week of
being shut in takes walks in nature
and does breathing exercises he also
starts doing simple activities such as
gardening drawing or painting during
this stage
the patient is still not allowed to talk
to anyone except the therapist
three occupational therapy five to seven
days
in this stage the patient performs tasks
that require physical movement
dr morita like to take his patients to
the mountains to chop wood
in addition to physical tasks the
patient is also immersed in other
activities such as
writing painting or making ceramics
the patient can speak with others at
this stage but only about the tasks at
hand
four the return to social life and the
real world
the patient leaves the hospital and is
reintroduced to social life
but maintains the practices of
meditation and occupational therapy
developed during treatment
the idea is to re-enter society as a new
person with a sense of purpose
and without being controlled by social
or emotional pressures
nikon meditation
morita was a great zen master of nikon
introspective meditation
much of his therapy draws on his
knowledge and mastery of this school
which centers on three questions the
individual must ask him or herself
one what have i received from person x
two what have i given to person x
three what problems have i caused person
x
through these reflections we stop
identifying others as the cause of our
problems
and deepen our own sense of
responsibility as morita said
if you are angry and want to fight think
about it for three days before coming to
blows
after three days the intense desire to
fight will pass on its own
and now ikigai
logotherapy and morita therapy are both
grounded in a personal
unique experience that you can access
without therapists or spiritual retreats
the mission of finding your ikigai your
existential fuel
once you find it it's only a matter of
having the courage
and making the effort to stay on the
right path
in the following chapters we'll take a
look at the basic tools you'll need to
get moving along that path
finding flow in the tasks you've chosen
to do eating in a balanced and mindful
way
doing low intensity exercise and
learning not to give in when
difficulties arise
in order to do this you have to accept
that the world like the people who live
in it
is imperfect but that it's still full of
opportunities for growth and achievement
are you ready to throw yourself into
your passion as if it were the most
important thing in the world
chapter four find flow in everything you
do
how to turn work and free time into
spaces for growth
we are what we repeatedly do excellence
then
is not an act but a habit
aristotle
going with the flow
imagine you're skiing down one of your
favorite slopes powdery snow flies up on
both sides of you like white sand
conditions are perfect you are entirely
focused on skiing as well as you can
you know exactly how to move at each
moment there is no future
no past there is only the present
you feel the snow your skis your body
and your consciousness united as a
single entity
you are completely immersed in the
experience
not thinking about or distracted by
anything else
your ego dissolves and you become part
of what you're doing
this is the kind of experience bruce lee
described with his famous
be water my friend we've all felt our
sense of time vanish when we lose
ourselves in an activity we enjoy
we start cooking and before we know it
several hours have passed
we spend an afternoon with a book and
forget about the world going by
until we notice the sunset and realize
we haven't eaten dinner
we go surfing and don't realize how many
hours we've spent in the water until the
next day when our muscles ache
the opposite can also happen when we
have to complete a task we don't want to
do every minute feels like a lifetime
and we can't stop looking at our watch
as the quip attributed to einstein goes
put your hand on a hot stove for a
minute and it seems like an hour
sit with a pretty girl for an hour and
it seems like a minute
that is relativity the funny thing is
that someone else might really enjoy the
same task
but we want to finish as quickly as
possible
what makes us enjoy doing something so
much that we forget about whatever
worries we might have while we do it
when are we happiest these questions
can help us discover our ikigai
the power of flow
these questions are also at the heart of
psychologist mihai chiksan mihai's
research into the experience of
being completely immersed in what we're
doing
chiksan mihai called this state flow
and described it as the pleasure delight
creativity and process when we are
completely
immersed in life there is no magic
recipe for finding happiness
for living according to your ikigai but
one key ingredient is the ability to
reach the state of flow
and through this state heaven optimal
experience
in order to achieve this optimal
experience we have to focus on
increasing the time we spend on
activities that bring us to this state
of flow
rather than allowing ourselves to get
caught up in activities that offer
immediate pleasure
like eating too much abusing drugs or
alcohol or stuffing ourselves with
chocolate in front of the tv
as chicks and mihai asserts in his book
flow
the psychology of optimal experience
flow is
the state in which people are so
involved in an activity that nothing
else seems to matter
the experience itself is so enjoyable
that people will do it
even at great cost for the sheer sake of
doing it
it's not only creative professionals who
require the high doses of concentration
that promote flow
most athletes chess players and
engineers also spend much of their time
on activities that bring them to this
state
according to chicks and mihai's research
a chess player
feels the same way upon entering a state
of flow as a mathematician working on a
formula
or a surgeon performing an operation
a professor of psychology cheeks and
mihi analyzed data from people around
the world
and discovered that flow is the same
among individuals of all ages
and cultures in new york and okinawa
we all reach a state of flow in the same
way
but what happens to our mind when we're
in that state
when we flow we're focused on a concrete
task without any distractions
our mind is in order the opposite occurs
when we try to do something while our
mind is on other things
the seven conditions for achieving flow
according to researcher owen shaffer of
depaul university
the requirements for achieving flow are
one
knowing what to do two knowing how to do
it
three knowing how well you're doing
four knowing where to go where
navigation is involved
five perceiving significant challenges
six perceiving significant skills
seven being free from distractions
if you often find yourself losing focus
while working on something you consider
important
there are several strategies you can
employ to increase your chances of
achieving flow
strategy number one choose a difficult
task but not too difficult
shaffer's model encourages us to take on
tasks that we have a chance of
completing but that are slightly outside
our comfort zone
every task sport or job has a set of
rules
and we need a set of skills to follow
them if the rules for completing a task
or achieving a purpose are too basic
relative to our skill set
we'll likely get bored activities that
are too easy
lead to apathy if on the other hand we
assign ourselves to a task that is too
difficult
we won't have the skills to complete it
and will almost certainly give up
and feel frustrated to boot the ideal is
to find a middle path something aligned
with our abilities but just a bit of a
stretch
so we experience it as a challenge
that's what ernest hemingway meant when
he said
sometimes i write better than i can
we want to see challenges through to the
end because we enjoy the feeling of
pushing ourselves
bertrand russell expressed a similar
idea when he said
to be able to concentrate for a
considerable amount of time
is essential to difficult achievement if
you're a graphic designer
learn a new software program for your
next project
if you're a programmer use a new
programming language
if you're a dancer try to incorporate
into your next routine a movement that
has seemed impossible for years
add a little something extra something
that takes you out of your comfort zone
even doing something as simple as
reading means following certain rules
having certain abilities and knowledge
if we set out to read a book on quantum
mechanics for specialists in physics
without being specialists in physics
ourselves
will probably give up after a few
minutes on the other end of the spectrum
if we already know everything a book has
to tell us we'll get bored right away
however if the book is appropriate to
our knowledge and abilities
and builds on what we already know we'll
immerse ourselves in our reading
and time will flow this pleasure and
satisfaction are evidence that we are in
tune with our
ikigai in summary easy tasks lead to
boredom
challenging tasks lead to flow tasks
beyond our abilities
lead to anxiety
strategy two have a clear concrete
objective
video games played in moderation board
games and sports
are great ways to achieve flow because
the objective tends to be very clear
beat your rival or your own record while
following a set of explicitly defined
rules
unfortunately the objective isn't quite
as clear in most situations
according to a study by boston
consulting group when asked about their
bosses
the number one complaint of employees at
multinational corporations is that
they don't communicate the team's
mission clearly
and that as a result the employees don't
know what their objectives are
what often happens especially in big
companies is that the executives get
lost in the details of obsessive
planning
creating strategies to hide the fact
that they don't have a clear objective
it's like heading out to sea with a map
but no destination
it's much more important to have a
compass pointing to a concrete objective
than to have a map joy ito
director of the mit media lab encourages
us to use the principle of
compass over maps as a tool to navigate
our world of uncertainty
in the book whiplash how to survive our
faster future
he and jeff howell write in an
increasingly unpredictable world moving
ever more quickly
a detailed map may lead you deep into
the woods at an unnecessarily high cost
a good compass though will always take
you where you need to go
it doesn't mean that you should start
your journey without any idea where
you're going
what it does mean is understanding that
while the path to your goal may not be
straight
you'll finish faster and more
efficiently than you would have if you
had trudged along a pre-planned route
in business the creative professions and
education alike
it's important to reflect on what we
hope to achieve before starting to work
study or make something we should ask
ourselves questions such as
what is my objective for today's session
in the studio
how many words am i going to write today
for the article coming out next month
what is my team's mission how fast will
i set the metronome tomorrow in order
to play that sonata at an allegro temple
by the end of the week
having a clear objective is important in
achieving flow
but we also have to know how to leave it
behind when we get down to business
once the journey has begun we should
keep this objective in mind
without obsessing over it when olympic
athletes compete for a gold medal
they can't stop to think how pretty the
metal is they have to be present in the
moment
they have to flow if they lose focus for
a second
thinking how proud they'll be to show
the medal to their parents
they'll almost certainly commit an error
at a critical moment and will not win
the competition
one common example of this is writer's
block
imagine that a writer has to finish a
novel in three months
the objective is clear the problem is
that the writer can't stop obsessing
over it
every day she wakes up thinking i have
to write that novel
and every day she sets about reading the
newspaper and cleaning the house
every evening she feels frustrated and
promises she'll get to work the next day
days weeks and months pass and the
writer still hasn't gotten anything down
on the page
when all it would have taken was to sit
down and get that first word out
then the second to flow with the project
expressing her icky guy as soon as you
take these first small steps
your anxiety will disappear and you'll
achieve a pleasant flow in the activity
you're doing
getting back to albert einstein a happy
man
is too satisfied with the present to
dwell on the future
to summarize a vague objective leads to
confusion
time and energy wasted on meaningless
tasks and mental block
a clearly defined objective and a focus
on process
leads to flow and obsessive desire to
achieve a goal while ignoring process
leads to a fixation on the objective
rather than on getting down to business
and mental block
strategy three concentrate on a single
task
this is perhaps one of the greatest
obstacles we face today with so much
technology
and so many distractions we're listening
to a video on youtube while writing an
email when suddenly
a chat prompt pops up and we answer it
then our smartphone vibrates in our
pocket
just as soon as we respond to that
message we're back at our computer
logging onto facebook pretty soon 30
minutes have passed
and we've forgotten what the email we
were writing was supposed to be about
this also happens sometimes when we put
on a movie with dinner
and don't realize how delicious the
salmon was until we're taking the last
bite
we often think that combining tasks will
save us time
but scientific evidence shows that it
has the opposite effect
even those who claim to be good at
multitasking are not very productive in
fact
they are some of the least productive
people
our brains can take in millions of bits
of information
but we can only actually process a few
dozen per second
when we say we're multitasking what
we're really doing is
switching back and forth between tasks
very quickly
unfortunately we're not computers adept
at parallel processing
we end up spending all our energy
alternating between tasks
instead of focusing on doing one of them
well
concentrating on one thing at a time may
be the single most important factor
in achieving flow according to cheeks
and mihai
in order to focus on a task we need one
to be in a distraction free environment
and two
to have control over what we're doing at
every moment
technology is great if we're in control
of it it's not so great if it takes
control of us
for example if you have to write a
research paper you might sit down at
your computer and use google to look up
the information you need
however if you're not very disciplined
you might end up surfing the web instead
of writing that paper
in that case google and the internet
will have taken over
pulling you out of your state of flow it
has been scientifically shown that if we
continually ask our brains to switch
back and forth between tasks
we waste time make more mistakes and
remember less of what we've done
several studies conducted at stanford
university by clifford ivar nass
describe our generation as suffering
from an epidemic of multitasking
one such study analyzed the behavior of
hundreds of students dividing them into
groups based on the number of things
they tended to do at once
the students who were the most addicted
to multitasking
typically alternated among more than
four tasks for example
taking notes while reading a textbook
listening to a podcast
answering messages on their smartphone
and sometimes checking their twitter
timeline
each group of students was shown a
screen with several red and several blue
arrows
the objective of the exercise was to
count the red arrows
at first all the students answered
correctly right away without much
trouble
as the number of blue arrows increased
the number of red arrows stayed the same
only their position changed however the
students accustomed to multitasking
had serious trouble counting the red
arrows in the time allotted
or as quickly as the students who did
not habitually multitask
for one very simple reason they got
distracted by the blue arrows
their brains were trained to pay
attention to every stimulus regardless
of its importance
while the brains of other students were
trained to focus on a single task
in this case counting the red arrows and
ignoring the blue ones
other studies indicate that working on
several things at once lowers our
productivity by at least 60 percent
and our iq by more than 10 points
one study funded by the swedish council
for working life and social research
found that a sample group of more than 4
000 young adults between the ages of 20
and 24 who were addicted to their
smartphones got
less sleep felt less connected to their
community at school
and were more likely to show signs of
depression
in summary concentrating on a single
task
makes achieving flow more likely
increases productivity
increases our power of retention makes
us less likely to make mistakes
helps us feel calm and in control of the
task at hand
causes us to become more considerate as
we pay full attention to those around us
and increases creativity multitasking
makes achieving flow impossible
decreases productivity by sixty percent
though it doesn't seem to makes it
harder to remember things
makes us more likely to make mistakes
makes us feel stressed by the sensation
that we're losing control
that our tasks are controlling us causes
us to hurt those around us through our
addiction to stimuli
always checking our phones always on
social media and
reduces creativity
what can we do to avoid falling victim
to this flow impeding epidemic
how can we train our brains to focus on
a single task
here are a few ideas for creating a
space and time
free of distractions to increase our
chances of reaching a state of flow
and thereby getting in touch with our
ikigai
don't look at any kind of screen for the
first hour you're awake
and the last hour before you go to sleep
turn off your phone before you achieve
flow there's nothing more important than
the task you've chosen to do during this
time
if this seems to extreme enable the do
not disturb function
so only the people closest to you
contact you in case of emergency
designate one day of the week perhaps a
saturday or sunday
a day of technical fasting making
exceptions for e-readers without wi-fi
or mp3 players go to a cafe that doesn't
have wi-fi
read and respond to email only once or
twice per day
define those times clearly and stick to
them
try the pomodoro technique get yourself
a kitchen timer
some are made to look like a pomodoro or
tomato and commit to working on a single
task as long as it's running
the pomodoro technique recommends 25
minutes of work and five minutes of rest
for each cycle
but you can also do 50 minutes of work
and 10 minutes of rest
find the pace that's best for you the
most important thing is to be
disciplined in completing each cycle
start your work session with a ritual
you enjoy and end it with a reward train
your mind to return to the present when
you find yourself getting distracted
practice mindfulness or another form of
meditation go for a walk or a swim
whatever will help you get centered
again
work in a space where you will not be
distracted if you can't do this at home
go to a library a cafe or if your task
involves playing the saxophone
a music studio if you find that your
surroundings continue to distract you
keep looking until you find the right
place
divide each activity into groups of
related tasks and assign each group its
own
place and time for example if you're
writing a magazine article
you could do research and take notes at
home in the morning
write in the library in the afternoon
and edit on the couch at night
bundle routine tasks such as sending out
invoices making phone calls and so on
and do them all at once a summary of the
advantages of flow
versus the disadvantages of distraction
a focused mind versus a wandering mind
living in the present versus thinking
about the past and the future
being free from worry versus having
concerns about our daily life
and the people around us invading our
thoughts
having the hours fly by versus having
every minute seem endless with flow we
feel in control
with distraction we lose control and
fail to complete the task at hand
or other tasks or people keep us from
our work
with flow we prepare thoroughly with
distraction we act without being
prepared
with flow we know what we should be
doing at any given moment
when distracted we frequently get stuck
and don't know how to proceed
with flow our mind is clear and
overcomes all obstacles to the flow of
thought
with distraction we're plagued by doubts
concerns
and low self-esteem with flow
it's pleasant with distraction it's
boring and exhausting
and with flow our ego fades we're not
the ones controlling the activity or
task we're doing
the task is leading us and with
distraction
constant self-criticism our ego is
present
and we feel frustrated
flow in japan takumi's
engineers geniuses and otakus
what do takumi's artisans engineers
inventors and otakus fans of anime and
manga have in common
they all understand the importance of
flowing with their ikigai at all times
one widespread stereotype about people
in japan is that they're exceptionally
dedicated and hardworking
even though some japanese people say
they look like they're working harder
than they really are
there is no doubt though about their
ability to be completely absorbed in a
task
or about their perseverance when there's
a problem to be solved
one of the first words one learns when
starting japanese lessons is
ganbaru which means to persevere or
to stay firm by doing one's best
japanese people often apply themselves
to even the most basic tasks with an
intensity that borders on obsession
we see this in all kinds of contexts
from the retirees taking meticulous care
of their rice fields in the mountains of
nagano
to the college students working the
weekend shift in convenience stores
known as conbinis
if you go to japan you'll experience
this attention to detail firsthand in
almost
every transaction walk into one of the
stores that sell handcrafted objects in
naha
kanazawa or kyoto and you'll also
discover that japan is a treasure trove
of traditional craft work
the people of japan have a unique talent
for creating new technologies
while preserving artisanal traditions
and techniques
the art of the takumi
toyota employs artisans who are able to
make a certain type of screw by hand
these takumi or experts in a particular
manual skill
are extremely important to toyota and
they are hard to replace
some of them are the only people who
know how to perform their exact skill
and it doesn't seem as though a new
generation is going to take up the
mantle
turntable needles are another example
they're produced almost exclusively in
japan
where you can find the last remaining
people who know how to use the machinery
required to make these precision needles
and who are trying to pass on their
knowledge to their descendants
we met at takumi on a visit to kumano a
small town near hiroshima
we were there for the day working on a
photo essay for one of the most famous
brands of makeup brushes in the west
the billboard welcoming visitors to
kamano shows a mascot holding a large
brush
in addition to the brush factories the
town is full of little houses and
vegetable gardens
heading farther in you can see several
shinto shrines at the base of the
mountains that surround the town
we spent hours taking photos in
factories full of people in orderly rows
each doing a single task such as
painting the handles of the brushes or
loading boxes of them onto trucks before
we realized we still hadn't seen anyone
actually putting bristles
into the brush heads after we asked
about this and got the run around
several times
the president of one company agreed to
show us how it was done
he led us out of the building and asked
us to get into his car
after a five-minute drive we parked next
to another smaller structure
and climbed the stairs he opened a door
and we walked into a small room filled
with windows that led in lovely natural
light
in the middle of the room was a woman
wearing a mask
you could see only her eyes she was so
focused on choosing
individual bristles for the brushes
gracefully moving her hands and fingers
using scissors and combs to sort the
bristles that she didn't even notice our
presence
her movements were so quick it was hard
to tell what she was doing
the president of the company interrupted
her to let her know that we'd be taking
photos as she worked
we couldn't see her mouth but the glint
in her eye and the cheerful inflection
in her speech
let us know she was smiling she looked
happy and proud
talking about her work and
responsibilities
we had to use extremely fast shutter
speeds to capture her movements
her hands danced and flowed in concert
with her tools and the bristles she was
sorting
the president told us that this takumi
was one of the most important people in
the company
even though she was hidden away in a
separate building
every bristle of every brush the company
made
passed through her hands
steve jobs in japan
apple co-founder steve jobs was a big
fan of japan
not only did he visit the sony factories
in the 1980s
and adopt many of their methods when he
founded apple he was also captivated by
the simplicity and quality of japanese
porcelain in kyoto
it was not however an artisan from kyoto
who won steve jobs devotion
but rather a takomi from toyama named
yokyo shakunaga
who used a technique called ecchu
satoyaki known by only a few
on a visit to kyoto jobs heard of an
exhibition of shakunaga's work
he immediately understood that there was
something special about shakunaga's
porcelain as a matter of fact he bought
several cups
vases and plates and went back to the
show three times that week
jobs returned to kyoto several times
over the course of his life in search of
inspiration
and ended up meeting shakunaga in person
it is said that jobs had many questions
for him almost all of them about the
fabrication process
and the type of porcelain he used
shakunaga explained that
he used white porcelain he extracted
himself from mountains in the toyama
prefecture
making him the only artist of his ilk
familiar with the fabrication process of
porcelain objects from their origins in
the mountains
to their final form an authentic takumi
jobs was so impressed that he considered
going to toyama to see the mountain
where shakunaga got his porcelain
but thought better of it when he heard
that it was more than four hours by
train from kyoto
in an interview after jobs death
shakunaga said he was very proud that
his work had been appreciated by the man
who created the iphone
he added that job's last purchase from
him had been a set of 12 teacups
jobs had asked for something special a
new style
to satisfy this request shakanaga made
150 teacups in the process of testing
out new ideas
of these he chose the 12 best and sent
them to the jobs family
ever since his first trip to japan jobs
was fascinated
and inspired by the country's artisans
engineers
especially at sony philosophy especially
zen
and cuisine especially sushi
sophisticated simplicity
what do japanese artisans engineers zen
philosophy and cuisine have in common
simplicity and attention to detail
it is not a lazy simplicity but a
sophisticated one that searches out new
frontiers
always taking the object the body and
mind or the cuisine to the next level
according to one ziki guy as cheeks and
mihai would say
the key is always having a meaningful
challenge to overcome
in order to maintain flow
the documentary jiro dreams of sushi
gives us another example of a takumi
this time in the kitchen its protagonist
has been making sushi every day for more
than 80 years
and owns a small sushi restaurant near
the ginza subway station in tokyo
he and his son go every day to the
famous tsukiji fish market
and choose the best fish to bring back
to the restaurant
in the documentary we see one of jiro's
apprentices learning to make tamago
a thin slightly sweet omelet no matter
how hard he tries
he can't get jiro's approval he keeps
practicing for years
until he finally does why does the
apprentice refuse to give up
doesn't he get bored cooking eggs every
day
no because making sushi is his ikigai
too
both jiro and his son are culinary
artists they don't get bored when they
cook
they achieve the state of flow they
enjoy themselves completely when they're
in the kitchen
that is their happiness their ikigai
they've learned to take pleasure in
their work
to lose their sense of time beyond the
close relationship
between father and son which helps keep
the challenge going each day
they also work in a quiet peaceful
environment that allows them to
concentrate
even after receiving a three-star rating
from michelin
they never considered opening other
locations or expanding the business
they serve just 10 patrons at a time at
the bar of their small restaurant
giro's family isn't looking to make
money instead
they value good working conditions and
creating an environment in which they
can flow while making the best sushi in
the world
jiro like yukio shakunaga begins his
work at
the source he goes to the fish market to
find the best tuna
shakunaga goes to the mountains to find
the best porcelain
when they get down to work both become
one with the object they're creating
this unity with the object that they
reach in a state of flow
takes on special meaning in japan where
according to shintoism
forests trees and objects have a kami
spirit or god within them when someone
whether an artist an engineer or a chef
sets out to create something
his or her responsibility is to use
nature to give it
life while respecting that nature at
every moment
during this process the artisan becomes
one with the object and flows with it
an ironworker would say that metal has a
life of its own
just as someone making ceramics would
say the clay does
the japanese are skilled at bringing
nature and technology together
not man versus nature but a union of the
two
the purity of jibli
there are those who say that the shinto
value of being connected with nature
is vanishing one of the harshest critics
of this loss is another artist with a
clearly defined ikigai
hayo miyazaki the director of the
animated films produced by studio ghibli
in nearly all his films we see humans
technology fantasy and nature in a state
of conflict
and in the end coming together one of
the most poignant metaphors in his film
spirited away
is an obese spirit covered in trash that
represents pollution of the rivers
in miyazaki's films forests have
personalities
trees have feelings and robots befriend
birds
considered a national treasure by the
japanese government miyazaki
is an artist capable of becoming
completely absorbed in his art
he uses a cell phone from the late 1990s
and he makes his entire team draw by
hand
he directs his films by rendering on
paper even the tiniest detail
achieving flow by drawing not by using a
computer
thanks to this obsession on the
director's part studio jeebly is one of
the only studios in the world
where almost the entire production
process is carried out using traditional
techniques
those who have visited studio ghibli
know that it's fairly typical on a given
sunday to see a solitary individual
tucked away in a corner hard at work
a man in simple clothes who will greet
them with an ohio
hello without looking up
miyazaki is so passionate about his work
that he spends many sundays in the
studio
enjoying the state of flow putting his
ikigai above all else
visitors know that under no
circumstances is one to bother miyazaki
who is known for his quick temper
especially if he is interrupted while
drawing
in 2013 miyazaki announced he was going
to retire
to commemorate his retirement the
television station nhk made a
documentary showing him in his last days
at work
he is drawing in nearly every scene of
the film
in one scene several of his colleagues
are seen coming out of a meeting
and there he is drawing in a corner
paying no attention to them
in another scene he is shown walking to
work on december 30th
a national holiday in japan and opening
the doors of studio ghibli so we can
spend the day there
drawing alone miyazaki can't stop
drawing
the day after his retirement instead of
going on vacation or staying at home
he went to studio ghibli and sat down to
draw
his colleagues put on their best poker
faces not knowing what to say
one year later he announced he wouldn't
make any more feature films
but that he would keep on drawing until
the day he died
can someone really retire if he's
passionate about what he does
the recluses
it is not only the japanese who have
this capacity there are artists and
scientists all over the world with
strong clear icky guys
they do what they love until their dying
day
the last thing einstein wrote before
closing his eyes forever was a formula
that attempted to unite all the forces
of the universe in a single theory
when he died he was still doing what he
loved
if he hadn't been a physicist he said he
would have been happy as a musician
when he wasn't focused on physics or
mathematics he enjoyed playing the
violin
reaching a state of flow while working
on his formulas or playing music
his two icky guys brought him endless
pleasure
many such artists might seem
misanthropic or reclusive
but what they are really doing is
protecting the time that brings them
happiness
sometimes at the expense of other
aspects of their lives
they are outliers who apply the
principles of flow to their lives to an
extreme
another example of this kind of artist
is the novelist haruki murakami
he sees only a close circle of friends
and appears in public in japan only once
every few years
artists know how important it is to
protect their space control their
environment
and be free from distractions if they
want to flow with their icky guy
microflow enjoying mundane tasks
but what happens when we have to say do
the laundry mow the lawn or
attend a paperwork is there a way to
make these mundane tasks enjoyable
near the shinjuku subway station in one
of the neural centers of tokyo
there is a supermarket that still
employs elevator operators
the elevators are fairly standard and
could easily be operated by the
customers
but the store prefers to provide the
service of someone holding the door open
for you
pushing the button for your floor and
bowing as you exit
if you ask around you'll learn that
there is one elevator operator who has
been doing the same job
since 2004. she is always smiling and
enthusiastic about her work
how is she able to enjoy such a job
doesn't she get bored doing something so
repetitive
on closer inspection it becomes clear
that the elevator operator is not just
pushing buttons but is instead
performing a whole sequence of movements
she begins by greeting the customers
with a song like salutation
followed by a bow and a welcoming wave
of the hand
then she presses the elevator button
with a graceful movement
as though she is a geisha offering a
client a cup of tea
cheeks and mihai calls this microflow
we've all been bored in a class or at a
conference and started doodling to keep
ourselves entertained
or whistled while painting a wall if
we're not truly being challenged
we get bored and add a layer of
complexity to amuse ourselves
our ability to turn routine tasks into
moments of microflow
into something we enjoy is key to our
being happy
since we all have to do such tasks even
bill gates washes the dishes every night
he says he enjoys it that it helps him
relax and clear his mind
and that he tries to do it a little
better each day following an established
order or
set of rules he's made for himself
plates first forks second and so on
it's one of his daily moments of
microflow
richard feynman one of the most
important physicists of all time
also took pleasure in routine tasks w
daniel hillis
one of the founders of the supercomputer
manufacturer thinking machines
hired feynman to work on the development
of a computer that could handle parallel
processing
when he was already world famous he says
feynman showed up on his first day of
work and said
okay boss what's my assignment they
didn't have anything prepared so they
asked him to work
on a certain mathematical problem he
immediately realized they were giving
him an irrelevant task to keep him busy
and said
that sounds like a bunch of baloney give
me something real to do
so they sent him to a nearby shop to buy
office supplies
and he completed his assignment with a
smile on his face
when he didn't have something important
to do or needed to rest his mind
feynman dedicated himself to micro
flowing say
painting the office walls weeks later
after visiting the thinking machines
offices a group of investors declared
you have a nobel laureate in there
painting walls and soldering circuits
instant vacations getting there through
meditation
training the mind can get us to a place
of flow more quickly
meditation is one way to exercise our
mental muscles
there are many types of meditation but
they all have the same objective
calming the mind observing our thoughts
and emotions
and centering our focus on a single
object
the basic practice involves sitting with
a straight back
and focusing on your breath anyone can
do it
and you feel a difference after just one
session by fixing your attention on the
air moving in and out of your nose
you can slow the torrent of thoughts and
clear your mental horizons
the archer's secret
the winner of the 1988 olympic gold
medal for archery was a 17 year old
woman from south korea
when asked how she prepared she replied
that the most important part of her
training was
meditating for two hours each day
if we want to get better at reaching a
state of flow meditation
is an excellent antidote to our
smartphones and their notifications
constantly clamoring for our attention
one of the most common mistakes among
people starting to meditate
is worrying about doing it right
achieving
absolute mental silence or reaching
nirvana
the most important thing is to focus on
the journey
since the mind is a constant swirl of
thoughts ideas and emotions slowing down
the centrifuge
even for just a few seconds can help us
feel more rested
and leave us with a sense of clarity in
fact one of the things we learn in the
practice of meditation
is not to worry about anything that
flits across our mental screen
the idea of killing our boss might flash
into our mind but
we simply label it as a thought and let
it pass like a cloud
without judging or rejecting it it's
only a thought
one of the sixty thousand we have every
day according to some experts
meditation generates alpha and theta
brain waves
for those experienced in meditation
these waves appear right away
while it might take half an hour for a
beginner to experience them
these relaxing brain waves are the ones
that are activated right before we fall
asleep
as we lie in the sun or right after
taking a hot bath
we all carry a spa with us everywhere we
go it's just a matter of
knowing how to get in something anyone
can do
with a bit of practice
humans as ritualistic beings
life is inherently ritualistic we could
argue that humans naturally follow
rituals that keep us busy
in some modern cultures we've been
forced out of our ritualistic lives to
pursue goal after goal
in order to be seen as successful but
throughout history
humans have always been busy we were
hunting cooking
farming exploring and raising families
activities that were structured as
rituals to keep us busy throughout our
days
but in an unusual way rituals still
permeate daily life
and business practices in modern japan
the main religions in japan
confucianism buddhism and shintoism are
all ones in which the rituals
are more important than absolute rules
when doing business in japan
process manners and how you work on
something
is more important than the final results
whether this is good or bad for the
economy is beyond the scope of this
audiobook
what is indisputable though is that
finding flow in a ritualistic workplace
is much easier than in one in which we
are continually stressed out trying to
achieve
unclear goals set by our bosses rituals
give us clear rules and objectives which
help us enter a state of flow
when we have only a big goal in front of
us we might feel lost or overwhelmed by
it
rituals help us by giving us the process
the sub steps on the path to achieving a
goal
when confronted with a big goal try to
break it down into parts
and then attack each part one by one
focus on enjoying your daily rituals
using them as tools to enter a state of
flow
don't worry about the outcome it will
come naturally happiness is in the doing
not in the result as a rule of thumb
remind yourself
rituals over goals
the happiest people are not the ones who
achieve the most they're the ones who
spend more time than others
in a state of flow
using flow to find your ikigai
after hearing this chapter you should
have a better idea of which activities
in your life make you
enter flow write all of them on a piece
of paper
then ask yourself three questions
what do the activities that drive you to
flow have in common
why do these activities drive you to
flow for example
are all the activities you most like
doing ones that you practice alone or
with other people
do you flow more when doing things that
require you to move your body
or just to think
in the answers to these questions you
might find the underlying icky guy that
drives your life
if you don't then keep searching by
going deeper into what you like by
spending more of your time in the
activities that make you flow
also try new things that are not on the
list of what makes you flow but
that are similar and that you're curious
about for example if
photography is something that drives you
into flow you could also try
painting you might even like it more or
if you love snowboarding and have never
tried surfing
flow is mysterious it's like a muscle
the more you train it the more you will
flow and the closer you'll be to your
ikigai
chapter 5. masters of longevity
words of wisdom from the longest living
people in the world
when we started working on this
audiobook we didn't want to just
research the factors that contribute to
a long and happy life
we wanted to hear from the true masters
of this art
the interviews we conducted in okinawa
merit their own chapter but
in the section that precedes it we've
provided an overview of the life
philosophies of a few international
champions of longevity
we're talking about super centenarians
people who live to 110 years of age or
more
the term was coined in 1970 by norris
mcwhorter
editor of the guinness book of world
records its use became more widespread
in the 1990s
after it appeared in william strauss and
neil howe's generations
today there are an estimated 300 to 450
super centenarians in the world
although the age of only around 75 of
them has been confirmed
they aren't superheroes but we could see
them as such for having spent far more
time on this planet than the average
life expectancy would predict
given the rise in life expectancy around
the world the number of super
centenarians might also increase
a healthy and purposeful life could help
us join their ranks
let's take a look at what a few of them
have to say
misaw okawa 117
eat and sleep and you'll live a long
time
you have to learn to relax
according to the gerontology research
group until april 2015
the oldest living person in the world
was misawkawa
who passed away in a care facility in
osaka japan after living for 117 years
27 days the daughter of a textile
merchant
she was born in 1898 when spain
lost its colonies in cuba and the
philippines and the united
states annexed hawaii and launched
pepsicola
until she was 110 this woman who lived
in three different centuries
cared for herself unassisted when
specialists
asked about her self-care routine misawa
answered simply
eating sushi and sleeping to which we
should add
having a tremendous thirst for life
when they inquired about her secret for
longevity she answered with a smile
i ask myself the same thing
proof that japan continues to be a
factory of long life
in july of the same year zakari momoy
passed away at 112 years and 150 days
old
at the time he was the oldest man in the
world though he was younger than 57
women
maria capovia 116.
i've never eaten meat in my life
born in ecuador in 1889 maria capovia
was recognized by guinness as the
world's oldest person
she died of pneumonia in 2006 at 116
years and 347 days old
leaving behind three children 12
grandchildren
and 20 great and
great-great-grandchildren
she gave one of her last interviews at
age 107 sharing her memories and her
thoughts
i'm happy and i give thanks to god who
keeps me going
i never thought i'd live so long i
thought i'd die long ago
my husband antonio capovia was the
captain of a ship
he passed away at 84. we had two
daughters and a son
and now i have many grandchildren and
great-grandchildren
things were better back in the old days
people behaved better
we used to dance but we were more
restrained there was this one song i
love dancing to
i still remember most of the words i
also remember many prayers
and say them every day i like the waltz
and can still dance it i also still make
crafts
i do some of the things i did when i was
in school
when she had finished recalling her past
she began to dance
one of her great passions with an energy
that made her seem
decades younger when asked about her
secret for longevity she responded
simply
i don't know what the secret to long
life is the only thing i do
is i've never eaten meat in my life i
attribute it to that
jean calm on 122.
everything's fine born
in aurel france in february 1875
jean calment lived until august 4th 1997
making her at 122 the oldest person of
verified age in history
she jokingly said that she competed with
methuselah
and there is no question that she broke
numerous records as she went on
celebrating birthdays
she died of natural causes at the end of
a happy life during which
she denied herself almost nothing she
rode a bicycle until she turned a
hundred
she lived on her own until 110 when she
agreed to move into a nursing home after
accidentally starting a small fire in
her apartment she
stopped smoking at 120 when her
cataracts started making it hard for her
to bring a cigarette to her lips
one of her secrets may have been her
sense of humor
as she said on her 120th birthday i see
badly i hear badly and i feel
bad but everything's fine
walter bruning 114
if you keep your mind and body busy
you'll be around a long
time born in minnesota in 1896
walter bruning was able to see three
centuries in his lifetime
he died in montana in 2011 from natural
causes
it had two wives and a 50-year career on
the railroad
at 83 he retired to an assisted living
center in montana
where he remained until his death he is
the second oldest man
a verified age ever born in the united
states
he gave many interviews in his final
years insisting that his longevity
stemmed from
among other things his habit of eating
only two meals per day
and working for as many hours as he
could your mind and your body
you keep both busy he said on his 112th
birthday
you'll be here a long time back then he
was still exercising every day
among bruning's other secrets he had a
habit of helping others
and he wasn't afraid of dying as he
declared in a 2010 interview with the
associated press
we're all going to die some people are
scared of dying
never be afraid to die because you're
born to die
before passing away in 2011 he is said
to have told a pastor that he'd made a
deal with god
if he wasn't going to get better it was
time to go
alexander emich 111
just haven't died yet
born in poland in 1903 alexander amich
was a chemist and parapsychologist
residing in the united states
who after the death of his predecessor
in 2014
became the oldest man of authenticated
age in the world
emmett himself died a year thereafter in
june of that year
leaving behind a long life rich with
experiences
amh attributed his longevity to among
other things
never drinking alcohol it's not as
though i'd won the nobel prize
he said upon being declared the world's
oldest man i never thought i'd get to be
so old
when asked about his secret to living so
long his answer was
i don't know i just haven't died yet
icky guy artists
the secret to long life however is not
held by super centenarians alone
there are many people of advanced age
who though they haven't made it into
guinness world records
offer us inspiration and ideas for
bringing energy and meaning to our lives
artists for example who carry the torch
of their ikigai
instead of retiring have this power
art in all its forms is an icky guy that
can bring happiness and purpose to our
days
enjoying or creating beauty is free and
something all human beings have access
to
hokusai the japanese artist who made
wood block prints in the ukioa style
and lived for 88 years from the mid-18th
to the mid-19th century
added this post script to the first
edition of his 100 views of mount fuji
all that i have produced before the age
of 70 is not worth being counted
it is at the age of 73 that i have
somewhat begun to understand the
structure of true nature
of animals and grasses and trees and
birds and
fishes and insects consequently at 80
years of age
i shall have made still more progress at
90
i hope to have penetrated into the
mystery of things
at 100 years of age i should have
reached decidedly a marvelous degree
and when i shall be 110 all that i do
every point and every line shall be
instinct
with life
following is our collection of some of
the most inspirational words from
artists interviewed by camille sweeney
for the new york times
of those still living none have retired
and all still enjoy their passion
which they plan to pursue until their
final breath demonstrating that when you
have a clear purpose
no one can stop you the actor
christopher plummer
still working at 86 reveals a dark
desire shared
by many who love the profession we want
to drop dead on stage
that would be a nice theatrical way to
go
osamu tazuka the father of modern
japanese manga
shared this feeling before he died in
1989
his last words as he drew one final
cartoon were
please just let me work
the 86 year old filmmaker frederick
wiseman declared on a stroll through
paris that he likes to work
which is why he does it with such
intensity everybody complains about the
rakes and pains and all that
but my friends are either dead or are
still working
he said carmen herrera
a painter who just entered her 100th
year sold her first canvas at 89
today her work is in the permanent
collections of the tate modern
and the museum of modern art when asked
how she viewed her future
she responded i am always waiting to
finish the next thing
absurd i know i go day by day
never stop learning you may grow old
and trembling in your anatomies you may
lie awake at night listening to the
disorder of your veins you may miss
your only love you may see the world
about you devastated by evil lunatics or
know your honor trampled in the sewers
of baser mines
there is only one thing for it then to
learn
learn why the world wags and what wags
it
that is the only thing which the mind
can never exhaust
never alienate never be tortured by
never fear
or distrust and never dream of
regretting
t.h white the once and future king
for his part naturalist and author
edward o wilson asserted
i feel i have enough experience to join
those who are addressing big questions
about 10 years ago when i began reading
and thinking more broadly about the
questions of
what are we where did we come from and
where are we going
i was astonished at how little this was
being done
ellsworth kelly an artist who passed
away in 2015 at the age of 92
assured us that the idea that we lose
our faculties with age is
in part a myth because instead we
develop a greater clarity
and capacity for observation it's one
thing about getting older
you see more every day i'm continuing to
see
new things that's why there are new
paintings
at age 86 the architect frank gehry
reminds us that some buildings can take
seven years from the time you're hired
until you're finished
a fact that favors a patient attitude
with regard to the passage of time
the man responsible for the guggenheim
museum bilbao however
knows how to live in the here and now
you stay in your time
you don't go backward i think if you
relate to the time you're in
you keep your eyes and ears open read
the paper see what's going on
stay curious about everything you will
automatically be in your time
longevity in japan
because of its robust civil registry
many of those verified as having lived
the longest are found in the united
states
however there are many centenarians
living in remote villages in other
countries
a peaceful life in the countryside seems
pretty common among people who have
watched a century pass
without question the international
superstar of longevity is japan
which has the highest life expectancy of
any country in the world
in addition to a healthy diet which we
will explore in detail
and an integrated health care system in
which people go to the doctor for
regular checkups to prevent disease
longevity in japan is closely tied to
its culture
as we'll see later on the sense of
community
and the fact that japanese people make
an effort to stay active until the very
end
are key elements of their secret to long
life
if you want to stay busy even when
there's no need to work there has to be
an icky guy on your horizon
a purpose that guides you throughout
your life and pushes you to make things
of beauty and utility for the community
and yourself
chapter six lessons from japan's
centenarians traditions and proverbs
for happiness and longevity
to get to ogimi we had to fly nearly
three hours from tokyo to naha
the capital of okinawa several months
earlier we'd contacted the town council
of a place known as
the village of longevity to explain the
purpose of our trip
and our intention to interview the
oldest members of the community
after numerous conversations we finally
got the help we were looking for
and were able to rent a house just
outside the town
one year after starting this project we
found ourselves on the doorstep of some
of the longest living people in the
world
we realized right away that time seems
to have stopped there
as though the entire town were living in
an endless here and now
arriving in ogimi after two hours on the
road from naha
we're finally able to stop worrying
about the traffic to our left or the sea
and an empty stretch of beach to our
right the mountainous jungle of
okinawa's yanbaru forests
once route 58 passes nago where orion
beer the pride of okinawa is made
it skirts the coast until it reaches
ogimi every now and then a few little
houses and stores crop
up in the narrow stretch of land between
the road and the base of the mountain
we pass small clusters of houses
scattered here and there as we enter the
municipality of oguimi
but the town doesn't really seem to have
a center our gps finally guides us to
our destination
the center for the support and promotion
of well-being
housed in an unattractive cinderblock
building right off the highway
we go in through the back door where a
man named tyra
is waiting for us beside him is a petite
cheerful woman who introduces herself as
yuki two other women immediately get up
from desks and show us to a conference
room
they serve us each a cup of green tea
and a few shikawasa
a small citrus fruit that packs a big
nutritional punch as we'll see later on
taira sits down across from us in his
formal suit and opens up a large planner
and a three-ring binder
yuki sits next to him the binder
contains a list of all the town's
residents
organized by age and club or moai
taira points out that these groups of
people who help one another are
characteristic of ogimi
the moai are not organized around any
concrete objective
they function more like a family taira
also tells us that volunteer work
rather than money drives much of what
happens in ogimi
everyone offers to pitch in and the
local government takes care of assigning
tasks
this way everyone can be useful and
feels like part of the community
ogimi is the penultimate town before
cape hedo
the northernmost point of the largest
island in the archipelago
from the top of ogimi's mountains we're
able to look down over the whole town
almost everything is the green of the
yanbaru jungle
making us wonder where the nearly 3 200
residents are hiding
we can see a few houses but they're
scattered in little clusters near the
sea or
in small valleys accessible by side
roads
communal life we're invited to eat in
one of ogimi's few restaurants
but when we arrive the only three tables
are already reserved
don't worry we'll go to churaumi instead
it never fills up
says yuki walking back to the car
she's still driving at age 88 and takes
great pride in that
her co-pilot is 99 and has also decided
to spend the day with us
we have to drive fast to keep up with
them on a highway that is sometimes more
dirt than asphalt
finally reaching the other end of the
jungle we can at last sit down to eat
i don't really go to restaurants yuki
says as we take our seats
almost everything i eat comes from my
vegetable garden and i buy my fish from
tanaka
who's been my friend forever the
restaurant is right by the sea
and seems like something from the planet
tatooine from star wars
the menu boasts in large letters that it
serves slow food
prepared with organic vegetables grown
in the town
but really yuki continues food is the
least important thing
she is extroverted and rather pretty she
likes to talk about her role as the
director of several associations run by
the local government
food won't help you live longer she says
bringing to her lips a bite of the
diminutive confection that followed our
meal
the secret is smiling and having a good
time
there are no bars and only a few
restaurants in ogimi
but those who live there enjoy a rich
social life that revolves around
community centers
the town is divided into 17
neighborhoods and each one has a
president
and several people in charge of things
like culture festivals
social activities and longevity
residents
pay close attention to this last
category
we're invited to the community center of
one of the 17 neighborhoods
it's an old building right next to one
of the mountains of the yanburu jungle
home to bunagaya the town's iconic
sprites
the bona gaia spirits of the yanbaru
jungle
bona gaya are magical creatures that
inhabit the yanburu jungle near ogini
and its surrounding towns
they manifest as children with long red
hair and like to hide in the jungle's
gajumaru
banyan trees and go fishing on the beach
many of okinawa's stories and fables are
about bonagaya sprites
they're mischievous playful and
unpredictable
locals say that the bunnagaya love the
mountains rivers
sea trees earth wind and animals and
that if you want to befriend them
you have to show respect for nature
a birthday party
when we arrive at the neighborhoods
community center we're greeted by a
group of about 20 people
who proudly proclaim the youngest among
us is 83.
we conduct our interviews at a large
table while drinking green tea
when we finish we're brought to an event
space where we celebrate the birthdays
of three members of the group
one woman is turning 99 another 94
and one young man has just reached 89.
we sing a few songs popular in the
village and finish up with happy
birthday
in english the woman turning 99 blows
out the candles
and thanks everyone for coming to her
party we eat homemade shikawasa cake
and end up dancing and celebrating as
though it were the birthday of a
20-something
it's the first party but not the last
that we'll attend during our week in the
village
we'll also do karaoke with a group of
seniors who sing better than we do
and attend a traditional festival with
local bands dancers
and food stands at the foot of a
mountain
celebrate each day together
celebrations seem to be an essential
part of life in ogimi
we're invited to watch a game of gate
ball one of the most popular sports
among okinawa's older residents
it involves hitting a ball with a
mallet-like stick
it's a low-impact sport that can be
played anywhere and it's a good excuse
to move around and have fun as a group
the residents hold local competitions
and there is no age limit for
participants
we participate in the weekly game and
lose to a woman who recently turned 104
everyone cheers and the defeated look on
our faces elicits laughter
in addition to playing and celebrating
as a community
spirituality is also essential to the
happiness of the village's residence
the gods of okinawa
the main religion in okinawa is known as
ryukyu
shinto ryukyu is the original name of
the okinawa archipelago
and shinto means the path of the gods
ryukyu shinto combines elements of
chinese taoism
confucianism buddhism and shintoism with
shamanistic and animistic elements
according to this ancient faith
the world is populated by an infinite
number of spirits
divided into several types spirits of
the home
of the forest of the trees and of the
mountains
it's important to appease these spirits
through rituals and festivals
and by consecrating sacred grounds
okinawa is full of sacred jungles and
forests
where many of the two main kinds of
temples are found
the uttaki and the uganju we visited an
ugandu or
small open-air temple adorned with
incense and coins
next to a waterfall in ogimi the uttaki
is a collection of stones where people
go to pray
and where supposedly spirits gather
in okinawa's religious practice women
are considered spiritually superior to
men
whereas the opposite is true of
traditional shintoism in the rest of
japan
utah are women chosen as mediums by
their communities to make contact with
the spirit realm through traditional
rights
ancestor worship is another important
feature of spiritual practice in okinawa
and in japan in general the home of each
generation's firstborn usually contains
a butt siddha
or small altar used to pray for and make
offerings to the family's ancestors
mabui every person has an essence or
mabui this mabui is our spirit
and the source of our life force it is
immortal
and makes us who we are sometimes the
mabui of someone who has died is trapped
in the body of a living person
this situation requires a separation
ritual to free them a buoy of the
deceased
it often happens when a person dies
suddenly especially at a young age
and his or her mobui does not want to
move on to the realm of the dead
hamabui can also be passed from person
to person by physical contact
a grandmother who leaves her
granddaughter a ring transfers a part of
her mabui to her
photographs can also be a medium for
passing mabui among people
the older the stronger
looking back our days in ogimi were
intense but relaxed
sort of like the lifestyle of the locals
who always seem to be busy with
important tasks but who
upon closer inspection did everything
with a sense of calm
they were always pursuing their icky guy
but
they were never in a rush not only did
they seem to be happily busy
but we also noticed that they followed
the other principles for happiness that
washington burnapp stated 200 years ago
the grand essentials to happiness in
this life are something to do
something to love and something to hope
for
on our last day we went to buy gifts at
a small market at the edge of town
the only things sold there are local
vegetables green tea and shikawasa juice
along with bottles of water from a
spring hidden in the yamburu forests
bearing labels that read longevity water
we bought ourselves some of this
longevity water and drank it in the
parking lot
looking out over the sea and hoping that
the little bottles that promised a magic
elixir would bring us health and long
life
and would help us find our own icky guy
then we took a photo with a statue of
abunagaya and walked up to it one last
time to read the inscription
a declaration from the town where people
live longest
at 80 i am still a child when i come to
see you at 90
send me a way to wait until i am a
hundred
the older the stronger let us not depend
too much on our children as we age
if you seek long life and health you are
welcome in our village
where you will be blessed by nature and
together we will discover the secret to
longevity
april 23 1993 oguimi federation of
senior citizens clubs
the interviews
over the course of a week we conducted a
total of 100 interviews
asking the eldest members of the
community about their life philosophy
their hiki guy and the secrets to
longevity
we filmed these conversations with two
cameras for use in a little documentary
and shows a few especially meaningful
and inspiring statements to include in
this section of the audiobook
one don't worry
the secret to a long life is not to
worry and to keep your heart young
don't let it grow old open your heart to
people with a nice smile on your face
if you smile and open your heart your
grandchildren and everyone else will
want to see you the best way to avoid
anxiety is to go out in the street and
say
hello to people i do it every day
i go out there and say hello and see you
later
then i go home and care for my vegetable
garden in the afternoon
i spend time with friends
here everyone gets along we try not to
cause problems
spending time together and having fun is
the only thing that matters
two cultivate good habits
i feel joy every morning waking up at
six and opening the curtains to look out
at my garden where i grow my own
vegetables
i go right outside to check on my
tomatoes my mandarin oranges
i love the sight of them it relaxes me
after an hour in the garden i go back
inside and make breakfast
i plant my own vegetables and cook them
myself that's my icky guy
the key to staying sharp in old age is
in your fingers
from your fingers to your brain and back
again if you keep your fingers busy
you'll live to see 100.
i get up at four every day i set my
alarm for that time
have a cup of coffee and do a little
exercise lifting my arms
that gives me energy for the rest of the
day
i eat a bit of everything i think that's
the secret
i like variety in what i eat i think it
tastes better
working if you don't work your body
breaks down
when i wake up i go to the butt sudan
and light incense
you have to keep your ancestors in mind
it's the first thing i do every morning
i wake up every day at the same time
early
and spend the morning in my vegetable
garden i go dancing with my friends
once a week i do exercise every day
and every morning i go for a little walk
i never forget to do my taiso exercises
when i get up
eating vegetables it helps you live
longer
to live a long time you need to do three
things
exercise to stay healthy eat well
and spend time with people
three nurture your friendships every day
getting together with my friends is my
most important iki guy
we all get together here and talk it's
very important
i always know i'll see them all here
tomorrow and that's one of my favorite
things in life
my main hobby is getting together with
friends and neighbors
talking each day with the people you
love that's the secret to a long life
i say hello and see you later to the
children on their way to school and
wave at everyone who goes by me in their
car drive safely
i say between 7 20 a.m and 8 15 a.m
i'm outside on my feet the whole time
saying hello to people
once everyone's gone i go back inside
chatting and drinking tea with my
neighbors that's the best thing in life
and singing together i wake up at five
every morning
leave the house and walk to the sea then
i go to a friend's house and we have tea
together
that's the secret to a long life getting
together with people
and going from place to place
4. live an unhurried life
my secret to a long life is always
saying to myself
slow down and relax
you live much longer if you're not in a
hurry
i make things with wicker that's my icky
guy
the first thing i do when i wake up is
pray then i do my exercises and eat
breakfast
at seven i calmly start working on my
wicker
when i get tired at five i go visit my
friends
doing many different things every day
always staying busy but doing one thing
at a time
without getting overwhelmed
the secret to long life is going to bed
early
waking up early and going for a walk
living peacefully and enjoying the
little things
getting along with your friends spring
summer
fall winter enjoying each season
happily five
be optimistic
every day i say to myself today will be
full of health and energy
live it to the fullest i'm 98 but
consider myself young
i still have so much to do
laugh laughter is the most important
thing
i laugh wherever i go i'm going to live
to be a hundred
of course i am it's a huge motivation
for me
dancing and singing with your
grandchildren is the best thing in life
i feel very fortunate to have been born
here i give thanks for it every day
the most important thing in ogimi in
life
is to keep smiling
i do volunteer work to give back to the
village a bit of what it is given to me
for example i use my car to help friends
get to the hospital
there's no secret to it the trick is
just to live
keys to the ogimi lifestyle
100 of the people we interviewed keep a
vegetable garden
and most of them also have fields of tea
mangoes
shikawasa and so on
all belong to some form of neighborhood
association where they feel cared for
as though by family they celebrate
all the time even little things music
song and dance are essential parts of
daily life
they have an important purpose in life
or several
they have an icky guy but they don't
take it too seriously
they're relaxed and enjoy all that they
do
they are very proud of their traditions
and local culture
they are passionate about everything
they do however insignificant it might
seem
locals have a strong sense of yui ma'aru
recognizing the connection between
people
they help each other with everything
from work in the fields harvesting
sugarcane or planting rice
to building houses and municipal
projects
our friend miyagi who ate dinner with us
on our last night in town told us that
he was building a new home with the help
of all his friends and that we could
stay there the next time we were in
ogimi
they're always busy but they occupy
themselves with tasks that allow them to
relax
we didn't see a single old grandpa
sitting on a bench doing nothing
they're always coming and going to sing
karaoke
visit with neighbors or play a game of
gate ball
chapter 7 the ikigai diet
what the world's longest living people
eat and drink
according to the world health
organization japan has the highest life
expectancy in the world
85 years for men and 87.3 years for
women
moreover it has the highest ratio of
centenarians in the world
more than 520 for every million people
as of september 2016.
while life expectancy in japan is high
overall okinawa exceeds the national
average
okinawa is one of the areas in japan
that were most affected by world war ii
as a result not only of conflicts on the
battlefield but also of hunger and a
lack of resources once the war ended
the average life expectancy was not very
high during the 1940s and 1950s
as okinawans recovered from the
destruction however they came to be some
of the country's longest living citizens
what secrets to long life to the
japanese hold
what is it about okinawa that makes it
the best of the best in terms of life
expectancy
experts point out that for one thing
okinawa is the only province in japan
without trains
its residents have to walk or cycle when
not driving
it's also the only province that has
managed to follow the japanese
government's recommendation of eating
less than 10 grams of salt per day
okinawa's miracle diet
the mortality rate from cardiovascular
disease in okinawa
is the lowest in japan and diet almost
certainly has a lot to do with this
it's no coincidence that the okinawa
diet is so often discussed around the
world at panels on nutrition
the most concrete and widely cited data
on diet in okinawa came from studies by
makoto suzuki
a cardiologist at the university of
ryukus who has published more than 700
scientific articles on nutrition and
aging in okinawa since 1970
bradley j wilcox and d craig wilcox
joined makoto suzuki's research team
and published a book considered the
bible on the subject
the okinawa program they reached the
following conclusions
locals eat a wide variety of foods
especially vegetables
variety seems to be key a study of
okinawa's centenarians showed that
they ate 206 different foods including
spices on a regular basis
they ate an average of 18 different
foods each day
a striking contrast to the nutritional
poverty of our fast food culture
they eat at least five servings of
fruits and vegetables every day
at least seven types of fruits and
vegetables are consumed by okinawans on
a daily basis
the easiest way to check if there's
enough variety on your table
is to make sure you're eating the
rainbow a table featuring
red peppers carrots spinach cauliflower
and eggplant for example
offers great color and variety
vegetables
potatoes legumes and soy products such
as tofu
are the staples of an okinawan's diet
more than 30 percent of their daily
calories
come from vegetables
grains are the foundation of their diet
japanese people eat white rice every day
sometimes adding noodles
rice is the primary food in okinawa as
well
they rarely eat sugar and if they do
it's cane sugar
we drove through several sugar cane
fields every morning on our way to ogimi
and even drank a glass of cane juice at
nakijin castle
beside the stall selling the juice was a
sign describing the anti-carcinogenic
benefits of sugar cane
in addition to these basic dietary
principles okinawans eat fish
an average of three times per week
unlike in other parts of japan the most
frequently consumed meat is pork
though locals eat it only once or twice
per week
along these lines makoto suzuki studies
indicate the following
okinawans consume in general one-third
as much sugar as the rest of japan's
population
which means that sweets and chocolate
are much less a part of their diet
they also eat practically half as much
salt as the rest of japan
seven grams per day compared to an
average of 12.
they consume fewer calories an average
of 1785 per day
compared to 2068 in the rest of japan
in fact low caloric intake is common
among the five blue zones
this brings us back to the 80 percent
rule we mentioned in the first chapter
a concept known in japanese as
harahachibu
it's easy to do when you notice you're
almost full but
could have a little more just stop
eating
one easy way to start applying the
concept of harahachi buu is to
skip dessert or to reduce portion size
the idea is to still be a little bit
hungry when you finish
this is why portion size tends to be
much smaller in japan than in the west
food isn't served as appetizers main
courses in dessert
instead it's much more common to see
everything presented at once on small
plates
one with rice another with vegetables a
bowl of miso soup and
something to snack on serving food on
many small plates
makes it easier to avoid eating too much
and facilitates the varied diet
discussed at the beginning of this
chapter
haruhachi bhu is an ancient practice the
12th century book on zen buddhism
zazen you recommends eating two thirds
as much as you might want to
eating less than one might want is
common among all buddhist temples in the
east
perhaps buddhism recognized the benefits
of limiting caloric intake
more than nine centuries ago
so eat less to live longer
few would challenge this idea without
taking it to the extreme of malnutrition
of course
eating fewer calories than our bodies
ask for seems to increase longevity
the key to staying healthy while
consuming fewer calories is eating foods
with a high nutritional value
especially superfoods and avoiding those
that add to our overall caloric intake
but
offer little to no nutritional value
the calorie restriction we've been
discussing is one of the most effective
ways to add years to your life
if the body regularly consumes enough or
too many calories
it gets lethargic and starts to wear
down expending significant energy on
digestion alone
another benefit of calorie restriction
is that it reduces levels of
igf-1 insulin-like growth factor 1
in the body igf-1 is a protein that
plays a significant role in the aging
process
it seems that one of the reasons humans
and animals age is an excess of this
protein in their blood
whether calorie restriction will extend
lifespan in humans is not yet known
but data increasingly indicate that
moderate calorie restriction with
adequate nutrition
has a powerful protective effect against
obesity type 2 diabetes
inflammation hypertension and
cardiovascular disease
and reduces metabolic risk factors
associated with cancer
an alternative to following the eighty
percent rule on a daily basis
is to fast for one or two days each week
the five two or fasting diet
recommends two days of fasting consuming
fewer than 500 calories every week
and eating normally on the other five
days among its many benefits
fasting helps cleanse the digestive
system and allows it to rest
15 natural antioxidants found in the
okinawan diet
antioxidants are molecules that slow
down the oxidation process in cells
neutralizing the free radicals that
cause damage and accelerate aging
the antioxidant power of green tea for
example is well known
and will be discussed later at greater
length
because they are rich in antioxidants
and are eaten nearly every day in the
region
these 15 foods are considered keys to
okinawan vitality
tofu miso tuna
carrots goya a bitter melon
kombu sea kelp cabbage
nori seaweed onion soy sprouts
hechima a cucumber like gourd soybeans
boiled or raw sweet potato peppers
and san pincha jasmine tea
senpincha the reigning infusion in
okinawa
okinawans drink more senpincha a mix of
green tea and jasmine flowers than any
other kind of tea
the closest approximation in the west
would be the jasmine tea that usually
comes from china
a 1988 study conducted by hiroko show at
the okinawa institute of science and
technology
indicates that jasmine tea reduces blood
cholesterol levels
saint pincha can be found in many
different forms in okinawa
and is even available in vending
machines in addition to all the
antioxidant benefits of green tea
it boasts the benefits of jasmine which
include
reducing the risk of heart attack
strengthening the immune system
helping relieve stress lowering
cholesterol
okinawans drink an average of three cups
of san pincha every day
it might be hard to find exactly the
same blend in the west but we can drink
jasmine tea or even a high quality green
tea instead
the secrets of green tea
green tea has been credited for
centuries with significant medicinal
properties
recent studies have confirmed its many
benefits and have attested to the
importance of this ancient plant in the
longevity of those who drink it often
originally from china where it's been
consumed for millennia
green tea didn't make its way to the
rest of the world until just a few
centuries ago
unlike other teas and as a result of
being air dried without fermentation
it retains its active elements even
after being dried and crumbled
it offers meaningful health benefits
such as controlling cholesterol
lowering blood sugar levels improving
circulation
protection against the flu vitamin c
promoting bone health
fluoride protection against certain
bacterial infections
protection against uv damage cleansing
and diuretic effects
white tea with its high concentration of
polyphenols
may be even more effective against aging
in fact it's considered to be the
natural product with the greatest
antioxidant power in the world
to the extent that one cup of white tea
might pack the same punch as a dozen
glasses of orange juice
in summary drinking green or white tea
every day
can help us reduce the free radicals in
our bodies keeping us young
longer the powerful
shikawasa
shikawasa is the citrus fruit par
excellence of okinawa
and ogimi is its largest producer in all
of japan
the fruit is extremely acidic it's
impossible to drink shikawasa juice
without diluting it first with water
its taste is somewhere between that of a
lime and a mandarin orange
to which it bears a family resemblance
shikawasas also contain high levels of
nobilitan
a flavonoid rich in antioxidants all
citrus fruits
grapefruits oranges lemons are high in
nobiliton
but okinawa's shikawasas have 40 times
as much as oranges
consuming nobilitan has been proven to
protect us from arteriosclerosis
cancer type 2 diabetes and obesity in
general
shikowasas also contain vitamins c and b
beta carotene
and minerals they're used in many
traditional dishes
and to add flavor to food and are
squeezed to make juice
while conducting research at the
birthday parties of the town's
grandparents
we were served shikawasa cake
the antioxidant cannon for westerners
in 2010 the uk's daily mirror published
a list of foods recommended by experts
to combat aging
among these foods readily available in
the west are
vegetables such as broccoli and chard
for their high concentration of water
minerals and fiber oily fish such as
salmon
mackerel tuna and sardines for all the
antioxidants in their fat
fruits such as citrus strawberries and
apricots
they're an excellent source of vitamins
and help eliminate toxins from the body
berries such as blueberries and goji
berries
they're rich in phytochemical
antioxidants
dried fruits which contain vitamins and
antioxidants and give you energy
grains such as oats and wheat which give
you energy
and contain minerals olive oil for its
antioxidant effects that show in your
skin
red wine in moderation for its
antioxidant
and vasodilatory properties
foods that should be eliminated are
refined sugar and grains
processed baked goods and prepared foods
along with cow's milk and all its
derivatives
following this diet will help you feel
younger and
slow the process of premature aging
chapter eight gentle movements longer
life
exercises from the east that promote
health and longevity
studies from the blue zone suggest that
the people who live the longest are not
the ones who do the most exercise
but rather the ones who move the most
when we visited oguimi the village of
longevity
we discovered that even people over 80
and 90 years old are still highly active
they don't stay at home looking out the
window or reading the newspaper
ogimi's residents walk a lot do karaoke
with their neighbors
get up early in the morning and as soon
as they've had breakfast or even before
head outside to weed their gardens they
don't go to the gym
or exercise intensely but they almost
never stop
moving in the course of their daily
routines
as easy as getting out of your chair
metabolism slows down 90 after 30
minutes of sitting
the enzymes that move the bad fat from
your arteries to your muscles where it
can get burdened off
slow down and after two hours good
cholesterol drops twenty percent
just getting up for five minutes is
going to get things going again
these things are so simple they're
almost stupid says gavin bradley in a
2015
interview with bridget schulte for the
washington post
bradley is one of the preeminent experts
on the subject and the director of an
international organization dedicated to
building awareness
of how detrimental sitting all the time
can be to our health
if we live in a city we might find it
hard to move in natural and healthy ways
every day
but we can turn to exercises that have
proven for centuries to be good for the
body
the eastern disciplines for bringing
body mind and soul into
balance have become quite popular in the
west but in their countries of origin
they've been used for ages to promote
health
yoga originally from india though very
popular in japan
and china's qigong and tai chi among
other disciplines
seek to create harmony between a
person's body and mind
so they can face the world with strength
joy and serenity
they're touted as elixirs of youth and
science has endorsed the claim
these gentle exercises offer
extraordinary health benefits
and are particularly appropriate for
older individuals who have a harder time
staying fit
tai chi has been shown among other
things to slow the development of
osteoporosis and parkinson's disease
to increase circulation and to improve
muscle tone and flexibility
its emotional benefits are just as
important it's a great shield against
stress and depression
you don't need to go to the gym for an
hour every day or run marathons
as japanese centenarians show us all you
need is to add movement to your day
practicing any of these eastern
disciplines on a regular basis is a
great way to do so
an added benefit is that they all have
well-defined steps and as we heard in
chapter 4
disciplines with clear rules are good
for flow
if you don't like any of these
disciplines feel free to choose a
practice that you love
and that makes you move following
we'll take a look at some of the
practices that promote health and
longevity
but first a little appetizer a
singularly japanese exercise for
starting your day
radio taiso this morning warm-up has
been around since before world war ii
the radio part of its name is from when
the instructions for each exercise were
transmitted over the radio
but today people usually do these
movements while tuned to a television
channel or
internet video demonstrating the steps
one of the main purposes of doing radio
tyso is to promote a spirit of unity
among participants
the exercises are always done in groups
usually in schools before the start of
classes
and in businesses before the work day
begins
statistics show that 30 percent of
japanese practice radio taiso for a few
minutes every morning
but radio tyso is one thing that almost
everyone we interviewed in oguimi had in
common
even the residents of the nursing home
we visited dedicated at least five
minutes every day to doing it
though some did the exercises from their
wheelchairs we joined them on their
daily practice and we felt refreshed for
the rest of the day
when these exercises are done in a group
it's usually on a sports field or in a
large reception hall and typically
involves some kind of loudspeaker
the exercises take five or ten minutes
depending on whether you do all or only
some of them
they focus on dynamic stretching and
increasing joint mobility
one of the most iconic radio tyso
exercises consists of simply
raising your arms above your head and
then bringing them down in a circular
motion
it's a tool to wake up the body an easy
mobility workout that is low in
intensity
and that focuses on exercising as many
joints as possible
it might seem basic but in our modern
lives we can spend days without raising
our arms above our ears
think about it our arms are down when
using computers
when using smartphones when reading
books one of the few times we raise our
hands over our heads is when
reaching for something in a cupboard or
closet while our ancestors were raising
their hands over their heads all the
time when
gathering things from trees radio tyso
helps us to practice all the basic
movements of the body
yoga popular in japan
as well as in the west yoga can be done
by almost anyone
some of its poses have even been adapted
for pregnant women and practitioners
with physical disabilities
yoga comes from india where it was
developed millennia ago to unite our
mental and physical elements
the word yoga itself comes from the
sanskrit term for yok
which refers to the cross piece that
binds draft animals to one another and
to the cart they're pulling
yoga strives to unite body and mind in
the same way
guiding us toward a healthy lifestyle in
harmony with the world around us
the main objectives of yoga are to bring
us closer to our
human nature mental and physical
purification
to bring us closer to the divine
styles of yoga
though all are oriented towards similar
goals there are many different types of
yoga that vary according to the
traditions and texts from which they
were developed
the differences among them lie as the
masters say in the path
taken to the summit of our best self
genre yoga the yoga of wisdom
the search for discipline and mental
growth
karma yoga focuses on action on tasks
and duties that benefit oneself and
one's community
bhakti yoga the yoga of devotion and
surrender to the divine
mantra yoga focuses on the recitation of
mantras to reach a state of relaxation
kundalini yoga combines diverse steps to
reach the desired mental state
raja yoga also known as the royal path
encompasses a range of steps geared
toward achieving communion with oneself
and others
hata yoga the most widespread form in
the west and japan
characterized by asanas or poses
combined in a quest for balance
how to do a sun salutation
the sun salutation is one of the most
iconic exercises in hatha yoga
to do it you simply have to follow these
12 basic movements
1. with your feet together stand up
straight
but keep your muscles relaxed exhale
two place the palms of your hands
together in front of your chest
from this position inhale as you raise
your arms above your head
and bend backwards slightly
three exhale as you bend forward until
you touch the ground with the palms of
your hands
without bending your knees
four stretch one leg back to touch the
floor with the tips of your toes
inhale five
bring the other leg back keeping your
legs and arms straight as you hold your
breath
six as you exhale bend your arms
and bring your chest to the ground and
then forward resting your knees on the
ground
seven straighten your arms and bend your
spine back
keeping the lower half of your body on
the ground inhale
eight with your hands and feet on the
ground lift your hips
until your arms and legs are straight
and your body forms an upside down v
exhale throughout the movement
nine bring forward the same leg you'd
stretch back earlier
and bend it so that your knee and foot
are aligned under your head
and between your hands inhale
ten exhale as you bring your back foot
forward and straighten your legs keeping
your hands on the ground
as in posture three
eleven bring your arms above your head
with your palms together and bend
backwards slightly as you did in posture
2 while you inhale
12. lower your arms to their initial
position
in mountain pose while you exhale
you've just greeted the sun now you're
ready to have a fantastic day
tai chi also known as tai chi chuan
tai chi is a chinese martial art that
can be traced back hundreds of years to
buddhism and confucianism
it's very popular in japan too according
to chinese tradition
it was created by the taoist master and
martial arts practitioner
chang song thung though it was yang
luchan who in the 19th century brought
the form to the rest of the world
tai chi was originally a negia or
internal martial art
meaning its goal was personal growth
focused on self-defense
it teaches those who practice it to
defeat their adversaries by using the
least amount of force possible
and by relying on agility tai chi
which was also seen as a means of
healing body and mind would go on to be
used more frequently to foster health
and inner peace to encourage its
citizens to be more active
the chinese government promoted it as an
exercise and it lost its original
connection to martial arts
becoming instead a source of health and
well-being accessible to all
styles of tai chi
there are different schools and styles
of tai chi the following are the best
known
chen style alternates between slow
movements and explosive ones
yang style the most widespread of the
forms characterized by slow fluid
movements
wu style utilizes small slow
deliberate movements hau style
centered on internal movements with
almost microscopic external movements
one of the least practiced forms of tai
chi even in china
despite their differences these styles
all have the same objectives
one to control movement through
stillness
two to overcome force through finesse
three to move second and arrive
first four to know yourself
and your opponent
the ten basic principles of tai chi
according to the master yang cheung fu
the correct practice of tai chi
follows ten basic principles
one elevate the crown of your head and
focus all your energy there
two tighten your chest and expand your
back
to lighten your lower body
three relax your waist and let it guide
your body
four learn to differentiate between
heaviness and lightness
knowing how your weight is distributed
five relax the shoulders to allow free
movement of the arms and promote the
flow of energy
six value the agility of the mind
over the strength of the body
seven unify the upper and lower body so
they act in concert
eight unify the internal and the
external to synchronize mind
body and breath
nine do not break the flow of your
movement
maintain fluidity and harmony
10. look for stillness in movement
an active body leads to a calm mind
imitating clouds
one of the best known movements in tai
chi consists of following the form of
clouds in an exercise called
wave hands like clouds here are the
steps
one extend your arms in front of you
with your palms down
two turn your palms to face in as though
you were hugging a tree trunk
three open your arms out to the side
four bring the left arm up and center
and the right arm down and center
five trace the shape of a ball in front
of your body
six turn your left palm toward your face
seven shift your weight to your left
foot
and pivot from your hip toward that side
while your eyes follow the movement of
your hand
eight bring your left hand to your waist
and your right hand in front of your
face
nine shift your weight to your right
foot
ten pivot toward your right looking at
your raised right hand the entire time
eleven repeat this movement fluidly
shifting your weight from one foot to
the other as you reposition your hands
twelve stretch your arms out in front of
you again
and bring them down slowly returning to
your initial position
qigong also known as chi
kung its name combines qi
life force or energy and gong work
indicating that the form works with the
individual's life force
though relatively modern especially
under its current name the art of qigong
is based on the tao yin
an ancient art meant to foster mental
and physical well-being
the practice began to appear in reports
on training and martial arts at the
beginning of the 20th century
and by the 1930s was being used in
hospitals
the chinese government later popularized
it as it had done with tai chi
qigong involves static and dynamic
physical exercises that stimulate
respiration in a standing
seated or reclined position there are
many different styles of qigong but
all of them seek to strengthen and
regenerate chi
though its movements are typically
gentle the practice is intense
benefits of qigong
according to numerous international
scientific studies qigong
like tai chi and yoga offer significant
health benefits
the following stand out among those
proven through scientific research
as observed by dr kenneth m sanser of
san francisco's qigong institute in his
article
medicinal applications of qigong
modification of brain waves improved
balance of sex hormones
lower mortality rate from heart attacks
lower blood pressure in patients with
hypertension
greater bone density better circulation
deceleration of symptoms associated with
senility
greater balance and efficiency of bodily
functions
increased blood flow to the brain and
greater mind-body connection
improved cardiac function reduction in
the secondary effects of cancer
treatments
practicing these arts not only keeps us
in shape it also helps extend our lives
methods for practicing qigong
in order to practice qigong correctly we
should remember that our life energy
flows through our whole body
we should know how to regulate its many
parts
1. regulating the body by
adopting the correct posture it's
important to be firmly rooted to the
ground
2. regulating the breath
until it is calm steady and peaceful
3. regulating the mind
the most complicated part as it implies
emptying the mind of thoughts
regulating the life force through the
regulation of the three prior elements
so that it flows naturally
five chow shen regulating the spirit
the spirit is both strength and root in
battle
as yang zhuang ming explains in the
essence of
taiji qigong in this way the whole
organism will be prepared to work
together toward a single goal
the five elements of qigong
one of qigong's best known exercises is
a series representing the five elements
earth water wood metal and fire
this series of movements seeks to
balance the five currents of energy
in order to improve brain and organ
function
there are several ways to do these
movements in this case we're following
the model of professor maria isabel
garcia monreal
from the qigong institute in barcelona
earth 1.
stand with your legs apart and your feet
directly below your shoulders
two turn your feet outwards slightly to
straighten the posture
three keep your shoulders relaxed and
down and your arms loose at your sides
slightly away from your body this is the
wu
chi or rooted posture
four as you inhale raise your arms in
front of you
until your hands are level with your
shoulders your palms facing down
five exhale as you bend your knees and
bring your arms down until your hands
are level with your stomach
your palms facing in
six hold this position for a few seconds
focusing on your breath
water starting from earth posture
bend your knees into a squat keeping
your chest upright and exhaling
throughout
two press your coccyx downward to
stretch your lumbar spine
three as you inhale stand to return to
earth posture
four repeat twice for a total of three
wood one starting from earth posture
turn your palms upward and open your
arms to the side
forming a circle as you inhale until
your hands are level with your clavicle
turn your hands so that your palms and
elbows point downward while keeping your
shoulders relaxed
two reverse the movement as you exhale
making a downward circle with your arms
until you reach your initial position
three repeat twice for a total of three
metal one
starting from earth posture raise your
arms until your hands are level with
your sternum
two turn your palms toward each other
about four inches apart with your
fingers relaxed and slightly separated
pointing upward
three as you inhale move your hands away
from each other until they are
shoulder-width apart
four as you exhale bring your hands
toward each other
until they are back in position two
five repeat twice for a total of three
observing the concentration of energy as
you bring your hands together in front
of your lungs
fire one
starting from earth posture bring your
hands level with your heart as you
inhale
with one hand slightly above the other
and your palms facing each other
two rotate your hands to feel the energy
of your heart
three turn from your waist gently to the
left
keeping your torso relaxed and your
forearms parallel to the ground
four with your palms still facing each
other
separate your hands bringing one up
until it is level with your shoulder
and the other down in front of your
abdomen
five turn from your waist gently to the
right
keeping your torso relaxed and your
forearms parallel to the ground
six as you exhale let your hands come
back together in front of your heart
seven with your palms still facing each
other
separate your hands bringing one up
until it is level with your shoulder
and the other down in front of your
abdomen
completing the series one
starting from earth posture inhale as
you bring your hands level with your
shoulders palms facing down
two as you exhale lower your arms to
rest at your sides
returning to the initial wu chi posture
shiatsu created in japan in the early
20th century
principally for the treatment of
arthritis shiatsu also works on energy
flow
through the application of pressure with
the thumbs and the palms of the hands
in combination with stretching and
breathing exercises it seeks to create
equilibrium among the different elements
of the body
the following quote is about the dao yin
a general term referring to the ancient
arts meant to foster mental and physical
well-being
it is not important that a dao yin have
a name
is imitating something or is engraved in
jade
what is important is the technique and
the essence of what is really practiced
stretching and contracting bending and
lifting of the head
stepping lying down resting or standing
walking or stepping slowly screaming or
breathing
everything can be a taoyin
breathe better live longer
the book shu chen shishu known in the
west as
10 books on the cultivation of
perfection dates back to the 13th
century
and is a compendium of materials from
diverse sources on developing the mind
and body
it quotes among others the celebrated
chinese doctor and essiest
son simeo who lived during the sixth
century
son simeone was a proponent of a
technique called the six
healing sounds which involves the
coordination of movement
breathing and pronouncing sounds with
the purpose of bringing our souls to a
place of calm
the six sounds are xu pronounced like
shh with a deep sigh which is associated
with the liver
h e pronounced like her
with a yawn which is associated with the
heart
s i pronounced like sir with a slow
exhale
which is associated with the lungs
c-h-u-i
pronounced like twi with a forceful
exhale
which is also associated with the
kidneys h-o-o
pronounced like who which is associated
with the spleen
and x i pronounced like she
which connects the whole body
the following poem by sun simeow offers
clues about how to live well according
to the season
it reminds us of the importance of
breathing and suggests that as we
breathe
we visualize the organs associated with
each of the healing sounds
in spring breathe
for clear eyes and so wood can aid your
liver
in summer reach for her so that
heart and fire can be at peace
in fall breathe sir
to stabilize and gather metal keeping
the lungs moist
for the kidneys next breathe twi
and see your inner waters calm
the triple heater needs your she to
expel
all heat and troubles in all four
seasons
take deep breaths so your spleen can
process food
and of course avoid exhaling noisily
don't let even your own ears hear you
the practice is most excellent
and will help preserve your divine
elixir
it might feel confusing to be presented
with all the eastern traditions we've
introduced in this chapter
the takeaway is that they all combine a
physical exercise
with an awareness of our breath these
two components
movements and breath help us to bring
our consciousness in line with our body
instead of allowing our mind to be
carried away by the sea of daily worries
most of the time we're just not aware
enough of our breathing
chapter 9 resilience and wabi-sabi
how to face life's challenges without
letting stress and worry age you
what is resilience
one thing that everyone with a clearly
defined icky guy has in common
is that they pursue their passion no
matter what they never give up
even when the card seems stacked against
them or they face one hurdle after
another
we're talking about resilience a concept
that's become influential among
psychologists
but resilience isn't just the ability to
persevere as we'll hear in this chapter
it's also an outlook we can cultivate to
stay focused on the important things in
life
rather than what is most urgent and keep
ourselves from being carried away by
negative emotions
in the final section of the chapter
we'll explore techniques that go beyond
resilience to cultivate
anti-fragility sooner or later we all
have to face difficult moments
and the way we do this can make a huge
difference to our quality of life
proper training for our mind body and
emotional resilience
is essential for confronting life's ups
and downs
nana kurobiaoki fall
seven times rise eight
japanese proverb resilience is our
ability to deal with setbacks
the more resilient we are the easier it
will be to pick ourselves up and get
back to what gives meaning to our lives
resilient people know how to stay
focused on their objectives
on what matters without giving into
discouragement
their flexibility is the source of their
strength they know how to adapt to
change into reversals of fortune
they concentrate on the things they can
control and don't worry about those they
can't
in the words of the famous serenity
prayer by reinhold nebor
god give us grace to accept with
serenity the things that cannot be
changed
courage to change the things which
should be changed
and the wisdom to distinguish the one
from the other
emotional resilience through buddhism
and stoicism
siddhartha gautama buddha was born a
prince of kapilavastu nepal and grew up
in a palace
surrounded by riches at 16 he married
and had a child
not satisfied by his family's wealth at
29
he decided to try a different lifestyle
and ran away from the palace to live as
an ascetic
but it wasn't asceticism that he was
looking for it didn't offer the
happiness and well-being he sought
neither wealth nor extreme asceticism
worked for him
he realized that a wise person should
not ignore life's pleasures
a wise person can live with these
pleasures but should always remain
conscious of how easy it is to be
enslaved by them
zeno obsidium began his studies with the
cynics
the cynics also led ascetic lives
leaving behind all earthly pleasures
they lived in the street and the only
thing they owned was the clothing on
their backs
seeing that cynicism did not give him a
sense of well-being zeno abandoned its
teachings to found the school of
stoicism
which centers on the idea that there is
nothing wrong with enjoying life's
pleasures
as long as they do not take control of
your life as you enjoy them
you have to be prepared for those
pleasures to disappear
the goal is not to eliminate all
feelings and pleasures from our lives as
in cynicism
but to eliminate negative emotions
since their inception one of the
objectives of both buddhism and stoicism
has been to control pleasure emotions
and desires
though the philosophies are very
different both aim to curb our ego
and control our negative emotions
both stoicism and buddhism are at the
roots methods for practicing well-being
according to stoicism our pleasures and
desires are not the problem
we can enjoy them as long as they don't
take control of us
the stoics viewed those who were able to
control their emotions as virtuous
what's the worst thing that could happen
we finally land our dream job but after
a little while we're already hunting for
a better one
we win the lottery and buy a nice car
but then decide we can't live without a
sailboat
we finally win the heart of the man or
woman we've been pining for
and suddenly we find we have a wandering
eye
people can be insatiable the stoics
believe that these kinds of desires and
ambitions are not worth pursuing
the objective of the virtuous person is
to reach a state of
tranquility apathy the absence of
negative feelings such as anxiety
fear shame vanity and anger and the
presence of positive feelings
such as happiness love serenity and
gratitude
in order to keep their minds virtuous
the stoics practiced something like
negative visualization they imagine the
worst thing that could happen
in order to be prepared if certain
privileges and pleasures were taken from
them
to practice negative visualization we
have to reflect on negative events
but without worrying about them seneca
one of the richest men in ancient rome
lived a life of luxury
but was nonetheless an active stoic
he recommended practicing negative
visualization every night before falling
asleep
in fact he not only imagined these
negative situations
he actually put them into practice for
example by
living for a week without servants or
the food and drink he was used to as a
wealthy man
as a result he was able to answer the
question what's the worst thing that
could happen
meditating for healthier emotions
in addition to negative visualization
and not giving into negative emotions
another central tenet of stoicism is
knowing what we can control and what we
can't
as we see in the serenity prayer
worrying about things that are beyond
our control
accomplishes nothing we should have a
clear sense of what we can change and
what we can't
which in turn will allow us to resist
giving in to negative emotions
in the words of epictetus it's not what
happens to you
but how you react that matters
in zen buddhism meditation is a way to
become aware of our desires and emotions
and thereby free ourselves from them
it's not simply a question of keeping
the mind free of thoughts
but instead involves observing our
thoughts and emotions as they appear
without getting carried away by them in
this way
we train our minds not to get swept up
in anger jealousy or resentment
one of the most commonly used mantras in
buddhism focuses on controlling negative
emotions
[Music]
in which om is the generosity that
purifies the ego
ma is the ethics that purifies jealousy
knee is the patience that purifies
passion and desire
pod is the precision that purifies bias
me is the surrender that purifies greed
and
whom is the wisdom that purifies hatred
the here and now and the impermanence of
things
another key to cultivating resilience is
knowing in which time to live
both buddhism and stoicism remind us
that the present is all that exists
and it is the only thing we can control
instead
of worrying about the past or the future
we should appreciate things just as they
are
in the moment in the now
the only moment in which you can be
truly alive is the present moment
observes the buddhist monk tiknot
in addition to living in the here and
now the stoics recommend reflecting on
the impermanence
of the things around us the roman
emperor marcus aurelius said that
the things we love are like the leaves
of a tree
they can fall at any moment with the
gust of wind
he also said that changes in the world
around us are not accidental
but rather form part of the essence of
the universe a rather buddhist notion in
fact
we should never forget that everything
we have and all the people we love
will disappear at some point this is
something we should keep in mind
but without giving in to pessimism being
aware of the impermanence of things
does not have to make us sad it should
help us
love the present moment and those who
surround us
all things human are short-lived and
perishable
seneca tells us the temporary
ephemeral and impermanent nature of the
world is central to every buddhist
discipline
keeping this always in mind helps us
avoid excessive pain
in times of loss
wabi-sabi and ichigo ichie
wabi-sabi is a japanese concept that
shows us the beauty of the fleeting
changeable and imperfect nature of the
world around us
instead of searching for beauty in
perfection we should look forward in
things that are flawed
incomplete this is why the japanese
place such value for example on an
irregular or cracked tea cup only things
that are
imperfect incomplete and ephemeral can
truly be beautiful
because only those things resemble the
natural world
a complementary japanese concept is that
of ichigo ichie
which could be translated as this moment
exists only now
and won't come again it's heard most
often
in social gatherings as a reminder that
each encounter
whether with friends family or strangers
is unique and will never be repeated
meaning that we should enjoy the moment
and not lose ourselves and worries about
the past or the future
the concept is commonly used in tea
ceremonies zen meditation
and japanese martial arts all of which
place emphasis on being present
in the moment in the west we've grown
accustomed to the permanence of the
stone buildings and cathedrals of europe
which sometimes gives us the sense that
nothing changes
making us forget about the passage of
time greco-roman architecture
adores symmetry sharp lines imposing
facades
and buildings and statues of the gods
that outlast the centuries
japanese architecture on the other hand
doesn't try to be imposing
or perfect because it is built in the
spirit of wabi-sabi
the tradition of making structures out
of wood presupposes their impermanence
and the need for future generations to
rebuild them
japanese culture accepts the fleeting
nature of the human being
and everything we create the grand
shrine of isa
for example has been rebuilt every 20
years for centuries
the most important thing is not to keep
the building standing for generations
but to preserve customs and traditions
things that can withstand the passage of
time
better than structures made by human
hands
the key is to accept that there are
certain things over which we have no
control
like the passage of time and the
ephemeral nature of the world around us
ichigo ichie teaches us to focus on the
present
and enjoy each moment that life brings
us this is why it's so important to find
and pursue our ikigai
wabi-sabi teaches us to appreciate the
beauty of imperfection
as an opportunity for growth
beyond resilience anti-fragility
as the legend goes the first time
hercules faced the hydra
he despaired when he discovered that
cutting off one of its heads meant that
two would grow back in its place
he would never be able to kill the beast
if it got stronger with every wound
as nasim nicholas talib explains in
antifragile
things that gain from disorder we use
the word fragile
to describe people things and
organizations that are weakened when
harmed
and the words robust and resilient for
things that are able to withstand harm
without weakening
but we don't have a word for things that
get stronger when harmed up to a point
to refer to the kind of power possessed
by the hydra of lerna
to talk about things that get stronger
when they are harmed tala proposed the
term
anti-fragile anti-fragility
is beyond resilience or robustness the
resilient
resists shocks and stays the same the
anti-fragile
gets better catastrophes and exceptional
circumstances offer good models for
explaining anti-fragility
in 2011 a tsunami hit the tohoku region
of japan
doing tremendous damage to dozens of
cities and towns along the coast
most famously fukushima when we visited
the affected coast two years after the
catastrophe
having driven for hours along cracked
highways and passed one empty gas
station after another
we passed through several ghost towns
whose streets had been taken over by the
remnants of houses
piles of cars and empty train stations
these towns were fragile spaces that had
been forgotten by the government and
could not recover on their own
other places such as ishinomaki and
kessinuma
suffered extensive damage but were
rebuilt within a few years
thanks to the efforts of many ishinomaki
and kisunuma showed how
resilient they were in their ability to
return to normal after the catastrophe
the earthquake that caused the tsunami
also affected the fukushima nuclear
power plant
the tokyo electric power company
engineers working at the plant were not
prepared to recover from that kind of
damage
the fukushima nuclear facility is still
in a state of emergency
and will be for decades to come it
demonstrated its
fragility in the face of an
unprecedented catastrophe
the japanese financial markets closed
minutes after the earthquake
which businesses did the best in the
aftermath
stock and big construction companies has
been steadily on the rise since 2011
the need to rebuild the entire coast of
tohoku is a boon for construction
in this case japanese construction
companies are anti-fragile
since they benefited enormously from the
catastrophe
now let's take a look at how we can
apply this concept to our daily lives
how can we be more anti-fragile
step one create redundancies
instead of having a single salary try to
find a way to make money from your
hobbies
at other jobs or by starting your own
business
if you have only one salary you might be
left with nothing should your employer
run into trouble
leaving you in a position of fragility
on the other hand
if you have several options and you lose
your primary job it might just happen
that you end up dedicating more time to
your secondary job
and maybe even make more money at it you
would have beaten that stroke of bad
luck
and would be in that case antifragile
one hundred percent of the seniors we
interviewed in oguimi had a primary and
secondary occupation
most of them kept a vegetable garden as
a secondary job and sold their produce
at the local market
the same idea goes for friendships and
personal interests
it's just a matter as the saying goes of
not putting all your eggs in one basket
in the sphere of romantic relationships
there are those who focus all their
energy on their partner
and make him or her their whole world
those people lose everything
if their relationship doesn't work out
whereas if they've cultivated strong
friendships
and a full life along the way they'll be
in a better position to move on at the
end of a relationship
they'll be anti-fragile right now you
might be thinking
i don't need more than one salary and
i'm happy with the friends i've always
had
why should i add anything new it might
seem like a waste of time to add
variation to our lives because
extraordinary things don't ordinarily
happen we slip into a comfort zone
but the unexpected always happens sooner
or later
step two bet conservatively in certain
areas
and take many small risks in others
the world of finance turns out to be
very useful in explaining this concept
if you have ten thousand dollars saved
up you might put
nine thousand dollars of that into an
index fund or fixed term deposit
and invest the remaining one thousand
dollars in ten startups with huge growth
potential
say one hundred dollars in each
one possible scenario is that three of
the companies fail
you lose three hundred dollars the value
of three other companies goes down
you lose another one or two hundred
dollars the value of three goes up
you make one or two hundred dollars and
the value of one of the startups
increases twentyfold you make nearly two
thousand dollars or maybe even more
you still make money even if three of
the businesses go completely belly up
you've benefited from the damage just
like the hydra
the key to becoming antifragile is
taking on small risks that might lead to
great reward
without exposing ourselves to dangers
that might sink us such as
investing ten thousand dollars in a fund
of questionable reputation that we saw
advertised in the newspaper
step three get rid of the things that
make you fragile
we're taking the negative route for this
exercise ask yourself
what makes me fragile certain people
things and habits generate losses for us
and make us vulnerable
who and what are they when we make our
new year's resolutions
we tend to emphasize adding new
challenges to our lives
it's great to have this kind of
objective but setting
good written skulls can have an even
bigger impact
for example stop snacking between meals
eat sweets only once a week gradually
pay off all debt
avoid spending time with toxic people
avoid spending time doing things we
don't enjoy simply because we feel
obligated to do them
spend no more than 20 minutes on
facebook each day
to build resilience into our lives we
shouldn't fear adversity
because each setback is an opportunity
for growth
if we adopt an anti-fragile attitude
we'll find a way to get stronger with
every blow
refining our lifestyle and staying
focused on our icky guy
taking a hit or two can be viewed as
either a misfortune
or an experience that we can apply to
all areas of our lives
as we continually make corrections and
set new and better goals
as talab writes in anti-fragile we need
randomness
mess adventures uncertainty
self-discovery
hear traumatic episodes all these things
that make life worth living
we encourage those interested in the
concept of anti-fragility to read nasim
nicholas talibs
anti-fragile life is
pure imperfection as the philosophy of
wabi-sabi teaches us
and the passage of time shows us that
everything is fleeting
but if you have a clear sense of your
ikigai each
moment will hold so many possibilities
that it will seem
almost like an eternity
epilogue ikigai
the art of living
mitsuo aida was one of the most
important calligraphers and haikus of
the 20th century
he is yet another example of a japanese
person who dedicated his life
to a very specific ikigai communicating
emotions with 17-syllable poems
using ashodo calligraphy brush
many of aida's haikus philosophies about
the importance of the present moment
and the passage of time one could be
translated as
in the here and now the only thing in my
life
is your life in another poem aida writes
simply
here now it is an artwork that seeks to
evoke feelings of
mana no aware a melancholy appreciation
of the ephemeral
the following poem touches on one of the
secrets of bringing ikigai into our
lives
happiness is always determined by your
heart
and one last one also by aida is
keep going don't change your path
once you discover your ikigai pursuing
it and nurturing it every day will bring
meaning to your life
the moment your life has this purpose
you will achieve a happy state of flow
in all you do
like the calligrapher it is canvas or
the chef
who after half a century still prepares
sushi for his patrons with love
conclusion our ikigai
is different for all of us but one thing
we have in common is that we're all
searching for meaning
when we spend our days feeling connected
to what is meaningful to us
we live more fully when we lose the
connection
we feel despair modern life estranges us
more and more from our true nature
making it very easy for us to lead lives
lacking in meaning
powerful forces and incentives money
power
attention success distract us on a daily
basis
don't let them take over your life our
intuition and curiosity are very
powerful
internal compasses to help us connect
with our hiki guy
follow those things you enjoy and get
away from or change those you dislike
be led by your curiosity and keep busy
by doing things that fill you with
meaning and happiness
it doesn't need to be a big thing we
might find meeting and
being good parents or in helping our
neighbors
there is no perfect strategy to
connecting with our achy guy
but what we've learned from the
okinawans is that we should not worry
too much about finding it
life is not a problem to be solved just
remember to have something that keeps
you busy doing what you love
while being surrounded by the people who
love you
the 10 rules of ikigai
we'll conclude this journey with 10
rules we've distilled from the wisdom of
the long-lived residents of ogimi
1. stay active don't retire
those who give up the things they love
doing and do well lose their purpose in
life
that's why it's so important to keep
doing things of value
making progress bringing beauty or
utility to others
helping out and shaping the world around
you even after your
official professional activity has ended
two take it slow
being in a hurry is inversely
proportional to quality of life
as the old saying goes walk slowly and
you'll go
far when we leave urgency behind
life and time take on new meaning
three don't fill your stomach
less is more when it comes to eating for
long life too
according to the 80 rule in order to
stay healthier longer
we should eat a little less than our
hunger demands instead of stuffing
ourselves
four surround yourself with good friends
friends are the best medicine there for
confiding worries over a good chat
sharing stories that brighten your day
getting advice having fun
dreaming in other words living
five get in shape for your next birthday
water moves it is at its best when it
flows fresh
and doesn't stagnate the body you move
through life in needs a bit of daily
maintenance to keep it running for a
long time
plus exercise releases hormones that
make us feel happy
six smile
a cheerful attitude is not only relaxing
it also helps make friends
it's good to recognize the things that
aren't so great but we should never
forget what a privilege it is to be in
the here and now
in a world so full of possibilities
seven reconnect with nature
though most people live in cities these
days human beings are made to be part of
the natural world
we should return to it often to recharge
our batteries
eight give thanks to your ancestors
to nature which provides you with the
air you breathe in the food you eat
to your friends and family to everything
that brightens your days and makes you
feel lucky to be alive
spend a moment every day giving thanks
and you'll watch your stockpile of
happiness
grow
nine live in the moment stop regretting
the past and fearing the future
today is all you have make the most of
it
make it worth remembering
follow your ikigai there is a passion
inside you
a unique talent that gives meaning to
your days and drives you to share the
very best of yourself until the very end
if you don't know what your ikigai is
yet as viktor frankl says
your mission is to discover it
the authors of this audiobook wish you a
long happy
and purposeful life thank you for
joining us
hector garcia and francesc miraes
you've been listening to ikigai the
japanese secret to a long and happy life
by hector garcia and francesc marais
narrated by walter dixon
if you've enjoyed this audiobook in this
performance then please visit our
website
gildanmedia.com that's
g-i-l-d-a-n-m-e-d-i-a-dot-com
where you'll find a wide selection of
titles in business and finance
personal development psychology and much
much more
and thank you for being a gildan audio
[Music]
listener
this has been a gildan audio production
for more affordable mind enriching
programs
visit our website at gildanmedia.com